Heed up the sizing here on footnote 33. This is a size down from
the other.
It's just funny that this is really, really, really frustrating
for him. Cherry did not treat Pisco any unique way last time.
That was Pisco. Pisco is a in debates. Pisco is annoying in debates.
He knows he is. That's why he should not get offended when somebody
yells at him and calls him a
So many people are like this. It's actually so annoying. if you
leave a comment like this. Oh, actually, um, well, I was gonna
I kind of liked you, but I'm gonna check back in a couple months
because like this is really annoying. Uh, yeah, banned. The people
Ethan said he doesn't want to go after the exact people he's
going after with his Denims lawsuit that he is going to create
an environment that them and he doesn't care because he doesn't
care about those people. All he cares about is his petty grievance.
His tiny petty grievance.
Pretty crazy. It's a lot of people who really hate Lykan. This
It's nuts. CIA director was called and seen outside the White
House like an hour ago. Okay. Well, it sounds like Yeah, we're
getting um It sounds like we're getting US participation. And
this is just an accurate
uh tweet from Lean. Why would it get him hate? Ethan pretty much
intentionally registered this to set these people up in a way
that even his legal bills will get covered, which is the funny
thing is is I don't think this has ever been about his legal
bills. Yes, they will get covered, but the only reason he wants
his legal bills covered as or as another form of fine on the
other person. He wants to financially harm these people, he wants
to try to financially destroy them as best he can. Yeah. So like
the fact that um well because even so if you make it seem like
you have a foolproof case and there's the threat that prolonging
it or fighting it means that all legal bills acred are going
to be on you. It makes the other person less likely to want or
even feel like they can fight you. Right. It is these are tactics
that make somebody want to settle. Yep. Yeah. It doesn't make
them change their opinions. doesn't make any of that stuff. But
yes, it is exactly that settling out of fear to minimize the
bill to you. Yeah. Well, and then you just say like admit that
you were wrong on some stuff, right? I I'm guessing would be
the settlement terms. You know what I mean? Like it would be
like, oh, go and say that you were wrong about this, that, go
um, you know, take down your criticisms of me, do all this stuff.
It's all the chill speech. It's all the chill criticism of him.
It's why he went after Noah Samson, right? Which, by the way,
is not going to go anywhere. It will not go anywhere. Oh, I forget
the Noah Samson thing. What's that? I don't think I was here
for that. Oh, he sued Noah Samson for defamation because Noah
Samson said he he thinks Oh, he thinks Ethan Klein supports a
genocide. Yeah. All of these people are like insanely gay. Yeah.
It's like it's all just talking on the internet and they all
basically would engage with it back and forth. Like I don't think
I don't think there's any reason to think Ethan is a more moral
actor than Denims. Ethan literally just had to settle a case
because he kept lying about this Ryan Kavanaaugh guy all over
the internet, right? Like Ethan's a pulling up like fake fake
stories. I think Quan said like it's it's like he's just a total
piece of [__] and he is trying to that's what gets
me. If he just if he would just embrace being a total piece of
[__] but he's trying to be like the the the hero
in this as well, which me off. Just admit that you're a piece
of like I'm doing this for you. Like no you're not. There's not
very much difference between you and denims. Like the idea that
you try to act like she's egregious and you have never been just
like a petty, it's just goofy. Yeah. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
But maybe that's what actually does it, right? Losing to Ryan
Kavanaaugh and actually having to like, you know, tuck his tail
between his legs and whimper
maybe motivates him to want to do that to someone else to sort
of like regain his manhood. That is kind of what it is. Regaining
your manhood. Hold on. What is this from Curios? What is this?
Why America's next war is heading to Mexico. Uh, this seems like
it could be cool. Go ahead, throw it in content suggestions.
Throw it up on the subre. Well, probably content suggestions
and we can we could possibly get to it, Kyoko.
But, uh, this could be kind of interesting. Wait, what is the
other thing you linked that wasn't Twitch safe? The Mexican Mormon
war, drug cartels versus Mormons, full length. Oh, weird. Okay.
Oh, this is like this might tie into Sorry, I'll pull that up
on screen just to see the the vice thing, but this might actually
tie into Isn't this why like Mitt Romney has a compound in Mexico?
I remember hearing conspiracies about this that Mitt Romney has
like a massive compound because he's a huge part of the Mormon
church. So, there's like a there a bunch of big Mormon compounds
in Mexico. It's like what the [__] are the Mormons
doing in Mexico? I have no idea. That might be actually interesting
at some point. look into why the Mormons have a bunch of down
in Mexico. He was born there. Oh, crazy. I didn't know that.
That's wild. Um, yeah, that's weird. We should look a little
bit I'm going to look a little bit more at these these uh tweets
here because I think going down through this thread will be important
for some of the other stuff we're going to cover today. Okay.
Um, Coney, did you have did you have those tweets? I think I
said if you could if you could link archives of those tweets
or if you have pictures of those tweets, I'd appreciate it cuz
I'd like to see C money says um why did Queen delete his tweets
defending denims. Um cuz I I just don't think that Queen is the
kind of person to delete something if he thinks he's wrong. So
I I don't know why he would have deleted them, but I'd have to
see what they were to know why they would be interesting
because he's a coward. I love it's just fun. Queen sucks off
Hassan and Co. That's why.
Okay, if that's what if that's how you want to take it. Uh, what's
wrong with sucking off his son? Jesus. Uh, Lyken says, "Holy,
Ethan actually registered the content nuke 3 days before release
so he could pull this stunt." I think the more interesting thing
is why did Ethan register his stream months later? Why did he
go and register his stream as one of the things months later?
H, that's that's more the weird one to me, but we'll see. Stunt
is when defending your copyright against malicious actors. So
again, copyright is a strict liability crime. Malicious malice
does not actually factor into it other than your your want to
sue them. Okay? You don't protect your copyright from malicious
actors. You protect your copyright, right? That's what you do.
You protect your copyright. If something is harming you, if something
somebody is using your like uh if somebody is using your intellectual
property and taking money away from you, you defend yourself.
You don't defend it against people who are doing it only maliciously.
That's like not a that's not a thing. Copyright infringement
is a strict liability crime. Malice is not a factor. Okay. The
actual damages, your actual harm, that's how copyright works,
right? Except in this one case where you can say malice uh leads
to statutory damages, right? Um but that's again, I don't know.
We'll see. Cuz I I would say probably the malice there is not
the malice of like I'm doing this to take money away from them.
It's probably the malice of like knowingly doing it, knowingly
using somebody's copyright and and trying to make money from
it, which probably that level of malice, I'm guessing, will it
apply to just about everybody else,
Yeah. But how does your hate for Destiny go into this opinion?
Hm. I don't know. Google disagrees. Google disagrees that copyright
infringement is a strict liability crime.
Wait, what? Where does Google disagree? He might be feeding Google
AI.
Uh, okay. I don't know how you missed my tweet. I did not miss
your tweet, Riyle. It is actually coming up. Don't worry about
it. Okay, don't worry about it. It's coming up. It's an important
thing. We'll we'll check it out. Okay. Sorry. We need to keep
going. I I just wanted to watch or I wanted to go through this
uh this whole thread. So, blah blah blah defending your copyright.
What uh way to say you support IP theft. Way to say you didn't
watch the video. What does he say in the video? Hold on. What
is this part? And it was in this setting that I formulated an
idea. What if I could make a long form irresistible piece of
this is literally like what honestly
and again people will get like really mad at Lykan but this person
has 600 likes here right son is when defending your copyright
against malicious actors and then Ethan literally in the video
goes what if I could make a video that they'd react to and then
I could copyright I could literally sue them. He literally talks
about doing this intentionally, right? I also wonder is this
video gonna help him in court? Like when you say, "I'm trying
to bait these people into doing this," right? Like you had a
back and forth with them where you were reacting to each other's
content over months and months and months and then you say, "I
was hoping I could bait them and then register this thing and
then get them on statutory damages. How is that going to help?"
By the way, just so you're aware,
oh, sorry, esports Batman is saying, um, oh, so the malice is
just willful infringement of the copyright. So yes, basically
it's very difficult to say you are not willfully infringing on
the copyright if you are intentionally watching the entire video
on stream, right? No, no, no, no, no. Uh, Cringle Nish, no, no,
no, no. This is obviously true. This is obviously true for all
of these people that they're intentionally infringing on the
copyright, right? Especially XQC. This makes it way more obvious
for XQC where XQC add almost no runtime to the video with his
reaction. XQC, I believe, says explicitly, "Oh, dude, I'm not
reacting. I'm just watching. I'm not reacting. I'm just watching,
guys. That's what he did, right? But we don't go after XQC. So,
this is the only part where you could try to say maliceuh comes
in at all, but it's just willful infringement. XQC literally
has a statement of willful infringement. He is literally the
person, if you're going on the moral crusade about lazy reacts,
that's the person you go after. He totally dodged it, right?
He totally dodges it cuz he doesn't want to get that smoke. He
wants to get people. He wants to get people in this thing. He
doesn't have to sue XQC. He does if he is trying to. So, here's
the thing, Shabby. This is what everybody needs to understand.
I think he's going to win this lawsuit. But what he tried to
do was release a video where he talked about how he wants to
defend the internet from lazy reacts. He does not. He does not
want to do that. That is not his goal. Denims did not do a lazy
react. and he actually explicitly edits the video to lie to lie
to you to all of his defenders who are and make them think that
Denims did a lazy react to the content nuke. She did not. She
did a totally standard react to the content nuke where she added
I think nearly as much time as the entire nuke itself of commentary.
He literally said, "Oh, sure, sure, sides." That's what I'm pointing
out. I'm pointing out that him referring to the 2023 ReactGate
stuff where he's always had a moral problem with this and that
he wants to save everybody from this which he has said multiple
times. He said it in his video multiple times. I'm trying to
protect you guys. I'm trying to protect the whole space from
lazy reacts. That is not true. That is clearly not true. And
he's trying to have his cake and eat it too. He's speaking out
of both sides of his mouth. Okay? That's what I'm telling you
is he is not like trying to be a hero here. So everybody has
to understand that this is just petty grievance. He set these
people up for a petty grievance. He doesn't care, right? He doesn't
care at all about the space. No, it's not a combination. It's
not a combination at all. If it was a combination and he really
cared about this, he would not have caught he would not have
tried to get Denims for the content nuke. You mean beforehand?
Yeah. No, no, she he wouldn't have tried to do it for the content
nuke. He would have just gone for the stream. Yeah, that's what
I mean. Because Denims did a legitimate reaction to the content
nuke. And I understand that there were other people conspiring
to try to push traffic to Denim's reaction to it, right, instead
of his and that she croed about it. And I I understand that hurts
you. But you are you are effectively attacking somebody who did
a full length react, like a full normal react. The people you
don't want to the people you don't want to target did similar
reacts, right? And you're now putting that in front of a judge.
So if a judge says, "Oh, that's clearly like a problem." And
they don't come down on just the market replacement thing. They
say, "Oh, actually, like because the full work is is used here,
oh, even with their interpersed commentary, like I don't think
this is legal." You've now opened up every single person who
does this kind of react to litigation in the future. And Ethan
doesn't care about that. The people Ethan said he doesn't want
to go after are the exact people he's going after with his denims
lawsuit. That he is going to create an environment that them.
And he doesn't care because he doesn't care about those people.
All he cares about is his petty grievance, his tiny petty grievance.
and representing it any other way is embarrassing. Pisco made
a really good point today, which um which kind of drives home
why it's a strict liability crime. Disney and basically every
other copyright holder that exists, they don't give a if you've
like bought one copyright tape and you go home and you infringe
on their copyright because you didn't want to give money to Disney,
right? They don't they don't give a about that. It doesn't matter
what somebody's intent is. It matters how much it hurts them,
how much it costs them, right? Disney will enforce their copyright
against somebody who's rebroadcasting to tens of thousands of
people because that's hurting them, right? That it's it's about
the damages. And the whole point of of this the the uh what is
it where you can do the 150,000 up to a maximum of 150,000 per
work infringed. This whole thing is like added for people going
after like peer-to-peer file sharing people. This was actually
meant to be just big companies bullying people out of behavior
they don't like. Right? That's what it was meant for. This is
literally a bully law. Nobody needs him to be a hero. That's
what he says he is. That is what he talked about.
He claimed that. Why are you guys ignoring that? He claimed that
I'm doing this because I want to save the space from lazy reacts.
Who cares about Wait. Okay, but who cares about that? I do. That's
why I'm talking about it, [__] What do you mean who
cares about that? I'm literally talking about how it's embarrassing
that he can't stand here and stand on business and just be the
petty that he is. No, that is that is great. So, the people who
are defending Ethan, you should come out now and be like, "No,
we don't need him to be like a hero." Uh, no, he's not a hero.
He's not doing this for anyone. He's just being petty and that's
based. Keep saying that and let's see how he reacts. Does he
start backing away from it because that is what he claimed that
he is.
So goofy. It's so It's all so goofy.
because
No, it's more for the people in my Discord to be honest with
you. I think if Ethan sees that the people who support him don't
even view him as a hero. Like they view him as being just petty
and going after these people like out of spite. If he sees that
he's got support and a following being that, maybe he leans into
it, right? Maybe he drops the act and he just starts being more
honest.
Yeah. Um Yeah, for sure. The funny thing is is I think he could
actually if he was really against lazy reacts, he could actually
only going go after the lazy reactors is where I am. I think
um what you pointed out so to go along with what you said which
you pointed out to me earlier was that obviously when he does
this and he's going after legal fees, it's not um like he set
this up all beforehand and I don't think he ever had any intention
of going after somebody who made enough money. I don't think
it had to do if XQC said he was doing it maliciously. I still
believe he wouldn't sue XQC. I think the reason he's doing this
is because of all of the drama that was happening, which I mean
is pretty much what he says, right? That it was because of the
drama from before. Like he he wanted to go after these creators.
That's who he was thinking about. I'm going to create a piece
of content for these creators. He wanted to bait these people
into reacting so he could see this was BS or any of that stuff.
Yes. This level of intent, this level of like spiteful hatred
towards these people existed before the CPS stuff, right? Oh,
that's actually a fantastic point that I don't recall you making
before that before the CPS stuff. That he wanted to ruin these
people's lives before the CPS stuff. That is his goal. I might
have missed it, but why is he not including Hassan? Because he
can't ruin Hassan financially through this. Do you think that
it's that I Okay, so I understand how financial debt or like
these lawsuits, it can ruin someone's life. In my mind, he just
wants to he wants to punish them or put them through
something more than uh how do I put
Simply responding to them and disagreeing with them isn't satisfying
enough. So, he wants to do something that actually affects them.
I don't know if that I don't know if you can say that suing somebody
that you have a right to sue is like your desire is to like ruin
their life. I think Ethan's just not capable of like arguing
through his issues with these people and so now he wants to take
them to court.
Yeah. Yes or no? If he am I incorrect? I sorry because he Sorry.
Say that again. Sorry. I got added and I read a message. Go again.
as I'm talking is a good time to just see what else is happening
over Discord or over chat rooms. N I Here, you know what? I'll
uh It's fine. Won't happen again. Can you please make your point
again? Okay, I lost it. I lost it. Okay. Uh All right. Okay.
Sorry. We're rolling through this. Um All right. So, Lyan actually
posts the part where he just says he is doing this maliciously.
He is trying to set them up to do this. That's his goal. Set
them up to do this. Right. This guy responds. So, what's your
argument? they that they deserve to steal content because they
were tricked into watching it. Is that really what you want to
go with? I I mean, for me here, if I were to make this argument,
it would be, hey, uh I think he basically wanted to hurt these
people financially. That's the goal. He wanted to do it before
the CPS stuff, before things got like really nasty. He's been
cooking this up. um when he couldn't get denims on the content
nuke specifically or when he thought that might go to some kind
of like uh fair use thing where she has an argument for fair
use. He also copyrighted his stream as well where she got up
and walked away. Right. I think I think this is just him realizing
that he can't make his arguments which I think was actually the
point you were making. He can't win his arguments so now he is
just going to win in the in the court of legal uh in the realm
of legality, right? He is going to take this to the the legal
world because he hasn't won it in the court of like public opinion.
Okay. Uh, I think it's ridiculous to feel like you should be
able to like squash someone's entire career because
they have a different opinion than you.
Um, I think there's no it's like not even a version of winning
an argument or winning a debate that justifies wanting to entirely
bankrupt somebody's
uh life. Yeah. And I think that's why it's really important to
highlight this was before the CPS stuff, right?
Uh Yeah. Like I'm I'm saying this because I think if if Denims
were to do the exact thing, I would be judging the out of her
as well.
And I thought her lawsuit when she attempted to file a lawsuit
against who was it? Was it Ethan or she talked about
embarrassing? He made the claims about the CPS thing against
her, right? Yeah. So, it was the it was an actual criminal thing
that she helped file that she was party to filing a fake um a
fake government form against him or something like the the CPS
call. The CPS form that got filled out, right? So, I think she
might have had some argument there. Maybe he sent a demand letter
to her, something through lawyers, right? That's what happened.
And then she raised money. I You're saying Ethan sent a demand
letter to her? Yeah. I thought something happened for her to
take that step. No.
I thought it was that he sued uh Noah Samson and then she basically
g did like more or less the same lawsuit back to him if I'm not
mistaken. Is that what I think it's something like that? I think
so. Yes, she sued him. Well, she she published I think she published
like a like a complaint. Oh, maybe was a demand letter. Was it
her thing for him to retract? But he uh didn't he then take it
back? He I think he did take it back. Abided by that. I think
I think there's Yeah, there there's a decent chance that some
conversation was had and it was like, "Okay, we'll like both
back off of some things and but also we're going to keep talking
about each other." Oh my goodness. That's why he's got her legal
name. Now I understand, right? Cuz if she sends a demand letter,
I think she she has to identify herself. Yeah, maybe. I think
there's probably also a lot of like unsavory ways you could get
her legal name as well.
I don't think I have to even consider those if she's literally
sent him a demand letter before any of this lawsuit happened.
Um, possibly. I wonder if she would have attached her legal name
to it or if she would have said like it this is denims. Like
I don't know if I don't know if to make a demand or to send a
demand letter. I don't know if you have to like probably to go
to court you might have to but it's like it's clearly identifying
who she is if she just says denims. But we'll see because I do
believe she's now claiming that Ethan doxed her, right? I do
feel like he doxed her. And I don't know if that's reasonable
or not for me to feel that way. Like I didn't even know Denim's
first name. Like that's how that's how much her information wasn't
out there. And now apparently there's like six different hyphenated
names that's like in this legal doc. Yeah, I that I think you
told me that as well that like basically her legal name was not
really findable and this is the first time it's ever been used.
And yeah, now she's she's actually making that complaint now.
I I thought it was weird that she wasn't complaining about it
and now she absolutely is. She absolutely is saying like I believe
he docks me. Like this is my name was not out here. I went to
great lengths to keep it. I think that's weird. I think it's
also weird that she hasn't complained about some like private
recording of her being posted on Bullyax like YouTube video.
I don't know. I feel like denim's under attack. And for what?
Just being a woman on the internet. Man up. She laughs at you
with her cleavage out. Her cleavage is out and she laughs at
you and you guys lost your mind.
There it is. All right, let's uh continue on with uh this thread
here. Did registering the IP with the state the Library of Congress
make Denims Frogan and Caseyron steal it? No. But making content
that was criticizing them and all of the content they've done
for the past like year probably did. Guaranteed they were going
to react to it. I would say again I think I think there's a chance
that Ethan's like even if Ethan wins this, there's a decent chance
that the damages are not that high because I feel like a judge
if you're a lawyer on the other side, you can easily build up
the argument, well, we had this back and forth going going going.
Yes, it got heated, but like there was an understanding that
we're we're criticizing each other and there is a back and forth
here, right? You built that understanding over a year and a half
and now you've tried to totally get rid of that because I mean
because you yeah you're you I think I think that's going to be
powerful. Oh, Lykan's getting brutally ratio ratio by this person
now. So they asked did did that make them steal it? No, but like
obviously that is a new element in what was like a pretty established
pattern. Anyway, it may hurt his legal case, copyright misuse,
copyright trolling, etc. not a lawyer, but provocations, which
he admits to, are usually not good for your case. Also, it's
petty and you would be mocking this and tearing it apart if it
came from Hassan. That's totally valid. I think if Assan had
done this to, let's say, uh, let's say Hassan had done this to
like Dylan Burns or something, right? Had set up like a video
and then Dylan Burns reacts and he's like, "Oh, Dylan Burns like
reacted." Let's say, again, Dylan Burns part of this culture
war. I'm using him as an example. I just picked a random person,
okay? They react to it. They laugh. They laugh even that they're
like reacting to it while it's premiering or something and like
they're taking views away and now suddenly they're open to like
having their lives destroyed via damages. I would think that's
really
Yeah. Second, but you don't count cuz you actually have your
own internal monologue. So, sorry. But anyway, um I don't I also
don't know if this hurts his legal case or not. I my intuition
would be yes that like when you state that you're trying to create
something so that other people will respond to it in full and
that you can sue them. I think that that has to hurt. But I feel
like it shouldn't, right? Because if you think about it, just
pointing out to people how you were able to protect yourself
and how you
from your past experience
know and can identify and even guess ways in which people are
going to
uh violate your the right to your content or something like that.
Like that can't hurt him. It just has to probably goes to show
that he is informed on this matter, right? You don't really hate
the police for setting up speed traps. They're identifying streets
that people tend to speed on. And it's the understanding that
you're supposed to follow the speed limit. And if you get caught
by these speed traps, that's not like, oh, the police set me
up. It's you're violating the law. Yeah. It's um it actually,
this is a really good thing. It's another strict liability thing,
right? Where it doesn't matter what the intent or circumstances
are. If you're violating the law, you're violating the law and
you can see the penalties under the law. So yeah, that's that
is correct that I don't think this would matter in the exact
same way that I talked about malice not mattering. I do think
that um I guess your your malice of forethought for on Ethan's
side also doesn't matter, right? It just matters whether or not
he was harmed. Yeah. And like for me, I think the only L here
is reputational damage. Like you okay, be be all within your
right. um go by the law and do everything that is like afforded
to you under the law, but in 4K in front of the rest of us, you
are mojo.
Like just evil. I mean, I think it's one of those things where
again to me like in in terms of the morality of this, he created
this back and forth over and over again. He created this back
and forth. We're all we're reacting to each other's stuff. He
he painted this as like the biggest thing. He called people out
to react to it. He didn't call them out to react to it, but he
called the people who have his who have he called out somebody
who had their exact positions, right? And said, "You're too much
of a to react to it. You're too much of a [__] to
react to it, right?" So, I understand I think there's something
there that you could argue he is granting some like some sort
of license to people. I They'll have to argue that. I don't know
if it'll work, right? But I think there's something there along
the lines of like I have not sued these people for reacting before
this. I think they've um he's created an environment where they
will react and then he's called out people who are adjacent to
these guys and saying you have to react to this. You if you don't
react to this you're a I think there's like some element being
built up there in the public eye that I think you could argue
on but we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. I think that people with
a lot of money who have just all the way
I don't know embodied their vanity from being celebrated on the
internet for so long. like you are rich, you are famous, and
you just you're like a bully now. You're kind of a miserable
bully. Well, he's always been a miserable bully, right? It's
just people his audiences are literally the people who like who
like that he's a miserable bully. Like who like they hate the
people he's bullying. He's just always been a miserable bully.
Yeah, I guess so. Okay. Yeah. Uh hold on. Uh I missed two of
these. Sod is bad. Sod is bad. I missed two of them. two of them.
That's crazy. Isn't literally everyone in the commentary? Oh,
so you can be a miserable bully without trying to use other tactics
that aren't just your speech, right? I think if you're in a realm
where everybody's talking, that's totally fine. But then because
you like talk and then you lose or you're not getting the effect
you want, right? People aren't buckling to your bullying and
then you go, "Well, you know what? Actually, I'm going to take
this from bullying to the courtroom. Let's go." I think that
that is like a move. That is like I'm calling my mom. You're
fighting with your brother and sister. Okay. You're fighting
fighting fighting and you I'm calling mom. How about you stop
being a punk [__]
Sorry. Go ahead, Jerry. No, you're fine. Um
it just it seems like what I said before where the idea that
okay, if you go after advertisers, if you go after the platform,
if you go after someone's channel, everybody in the community
looks at you sideways. Like, what the are you doing? You're crossing
a line. like this is fight club and that's the thing that you
don't do and he's found a way to literally singularly target
them in a way that like other people can't identify should also
be against Fight Club but because it's not going after like a
Twitch and because it's not going after advertisers he gets to
wiggle and make it and make other content creators almost feel
like no you shouldn't shame me or anything I'm not going too
far because he's figured out how to just singularly target these
three people that he has the grievance against and because usually
people will speak up like what Lyken's doing, what Pisco is doing,
what like you and Creeman are doing. He will normally will speak
up and make sure that the larger creators don't actually threaten
everybody in their pettiness and keep them in check. And I think
Ethan is intentionally trying to figure out a way to attack these
three people without invoking that check. Yes. From like his
peers. Here I Yes. And I found the I found the um there's like
a there is like a hypothetical here that works. I think it's
imagine that like the commentary community has always been like
street racing. Okay, street racing is illegal. We're all doing
something illegal. We all have like actually claims against each
other for endangering each other. We've all done this. We've
all agreed to it. We all participated in it. Now somebody is
actually suing one of the other street racers for doing that.
Okay. They have cases against everybody, but they picked up the
three people and they very strategically picked out the three
people that everybody else dislikes so that they can try not
so they so nobody calls them out for being a okay. They decided,
oh well, you know, I lost a race or like I haven't been able
to to drive these people out through racing. So actually now
I'm going to something else and even though we all participated
in this, we've all done it to some extent. I'm actually going
to try to go after you for street racing now. you uh Zan Kelly
and telling and telling the rest of the people like I'm doing
this for you. Yeah. Uh yes, exactly. I'm doing this for you.
Like look guys, like don't we all hate people who like fall asleep
at the wheel? I'm only suing people who fall asleep at the wheel
except
that Denim's react that he's actually talking about that he's
actually talking about is the same. It's just totally standard
street racing, right? But he's still suing her for it.
Do you see Asmin Gold reading the sick tweet? Nope. I haven't
gotten to a lot of the other stuff yet that we wanted to go to.
I'm I'm barely making it down this thread. This finally this
person's in the person that Lykan's like actually responding
to through all this. Yeah, it's like the street racing thing.
That's what's frustrating is everybody had this concept of like
we're all criticizing each other. We're all going back and forth.
Ethan said that he wanted criticism from people on this, right?
That is why he made it. That is the bait, right? That he said,
"Oh, it's really important that you guys criticize this. Watch
this and try to stand up to the criticisms." And then people
did it and then he got and he is not going after Denims for a
chair react as much as he tries to paint it that way. He is going
after Denims for doing a full substantial reaction to that video.
And it's going to all of us. Okay, that's the problem. We all
have this understanding. It's all built up this way. He's going
to get a precedent set that's like really gonna everybody who
street races and he does not care. That's even though he said
he cared, even though he said it he was doing it to protect them,
he is actually going to hurt them and he doesn't give a Sorry.
Go ahead. Because because of like who he is and the the resources
that he has, he's the one who's probably supposed to be more
mature and just know to contact a content creator, ask them,
"Hey, can you not do this or can you take this down? This was
kind of up." And like you're supposed to make some efforts before
you even tried to get a video taken down, let alone try to
another person. Do you understand?
Those are the insane things. Those are the things that it's like,
okay, you kind of um like everything about that should make other
content creators
like skin
Yes.
Also, because something has happened. Okay. Sorry, we have to
cover this just real quick. I hate to pop out for two. The US
actually hit the sites at Fordau. We have completed our very
successful attack on the three nuclear sites in Iran, including
Fordau, Natans, and Esvahan. All planes are now outside of Iran
airspace. A full payload of bombs was dropped on the primary
site, Fordau. All planes are safely on their way home. Congratulations
to our great American warriors. There is not another military
in the world who could have done this. Now is the time for peace.
Thank you for your attention to this matter.
It's so No, there's not World War II. It's not World War II.
It's just this guy I once again involving his once again just
totally bowing to Israel. Let's go Israel. Let's go Israel. It's
soing stupid.
It's sad. No. No. This is the nothing ever happens Chud losing.
But it's so I I would like want to cover this any other night,
but also this other stuff's better anyway. The Ethan stuff is
better. This is just depressing. It's just depressing. Also,
your your B2 bombers had no threat. All of the anti-air was gone.
They have no no radar that's capable of detecting a B2. Like,
it's it there's nothing they could do.
No new wars. Remember, I know it's
Anyway, are you sure this tweet is correct?
Uh, I mean, we could go over to Truth Social and see if Trump
did it, like said it, but I this OSN 613 site or PE person is
normally pretty Yeah. No, this is uh this is one minute ago.
Donald Trump. Yeah,
this is it. It happened. It happened. It's real. It's very Unless
Donald Trump just faked this, which I feel like he did not. Anyway,
that's our breaking news update, guys. Insane. Nick Fuentes would
call this a Chudney moment because it's along the prescribed
path. Maybe. It's just It's like depressing. It's just depressing
is all. That's it. That's it. That's all crazy.
Crazy. Okay, need to keep going through this thread.
God.
Ethan, what are you doing? What are you doing?
Okay. Uh, how did he provoke them? Oh, Lyan's going to make the
argument I did. Okay. How did he provoke them? Please tell me.
He said, "I knew they would steal my content, not I'm going to
make them steal my content." Well, he said he was laying a trap.
He literally said he was going to try to bait them. That's what
he said. He was trying to make it so that they would respond
to it, right? Do you think uh do you think is now going to stop?
The only correct answer is no. Yeah, probably no. You remember
Hassan not reacting and him repeatedly encouraging him to do
it on a show? Also, still not a lawyer, but I bet a skilled attorney
could argue his mentioning of people or showing their audience,
even with minimal commentary, is valid, or at the very least,
provocation. Also, why not submit a DMCA? This is what Cherry
was just saying. Why didn't you make full use of all of the tools?
Why did you not submit a DMCA? Why are you not upset about this?
Right?
Okay. The video is literally about Hassan and features various
transformed clips from Hassan's channel, hence why he's not suing
Hassan. Wait, there are a bunch of things about Frogan and Denims
in there, are there not? I could have sworn there was a ton of
things about Froen and Denims in this video.
I thought there was like 40 minutes of Froggen content in this
video. No, maybe not. Uh, that doesn't give Frogan, Denims, and
Caseyron the right to react to someone else's video with the
deliberate and stated intention of siphoning. By the way, also,
it features various transformative clips from Hassan's channel.
I don't know. That seems like something that would have to be
litigated. How exactly was it transformative? Was it in good
faith? Is it totally in good faith? I think there's at least
one of those things where Ethan's argument, by the way, Ethan's
argument with Denims is that her her transformative content is
not transformative because it's not right. It's not correct.
I think Ethan's got a piece in there where he totally misrepresents
something Hassan said, right? I forget what it is. You could
argue in effect it's not, but again, this could all go in front
of a court. Okay. Oh, anyway, that doesn't give Froggen, Denims,
and Casey Trron the right to react to someone else's video with
the deliberate and stated intention of siphoning views away from
it while providing very little transformative commentary. Denims
provided a ton of transformative commentary. That's And again,
all I can think based on how these people are reacting is that
the lie Ethan did worked perfectly. The misrepresentation Ethan
did worked totally perfectly. Let me pull up this uh this denim's
time stamp I had. Let me go find it. Let me go find it. Where
did I Where'd I put it? Where did I put it? where my time stamp,
right? And while you look for that, remember that one of his
legal arguments is that her commentary was wrong. So, because
she's stupid, that's why she shouldn't be able to react. Yes.
Yep. So, it's like uh she had the wrong opinion, the wrong idea,
the wrong response, and that's why this is egregious.
Exactly. That's the argument he made. I Sorry, my I don't have
my time stamp that I need. Uh, one second. I need to go find
it really quickly. Sorry, I need to I need this because it's
actually quite Oh, I It's lucky. Lucky it saved it for me. Could
be right here switches over to denim. People otherly button not
to steal when I was five. Up next is denims. And honestly, so
up next is denim. Not to steal when I was five. Up next is denims.
This is not coordination. This is not something you can hold
denims liable for. Unless you can prove that she wanted this
to happen, that she she set this up happening, right? This is
something that easily anybody who knows Ethan, who knows anything
about this entire like culture war that's been going on, could
easily make this post and say, "Here are the people who could
watch it, that you could go watch them instead." And honestly,
just take a look at this. Why would I not Why would I not just
create the idea that, hey, you're on top of this. You uh you
set up so that you can content library this or whatever like
that. You you did all of the like priming. Why? How do I know
that you're not the person that's in this Reddit setting her
up?
Yeah. You would need you need proof and you need proof that one
of those people didn't like basically do that from that exact
same point of view. Yeah. Yeah. You would need to you need to
show that like for some reason she wanted that that there's some
amount of
back and forth. Feel like it did not even say that like a person,
but do you know what I mean? Like there's no there's no proof
that you aren't the person dangling a carrot in front of Dem
Denim's face and then just using that to uh as proof like look
she's coordinating with this subreddit even though that's your
own gay ops in there.
Yeah, exactly. I mean that's a that's a what would you call that?
Reasonable doubt, right? That's like a you could you could cast
doubt on it, but um you're not saying that happened, but like
how do you know that that didn't happen? Oh, I didn't notice
that he also put her name her full name in his video as well.
Cool. Very cool of him. Very cool of him.
Is that red thread in the court paper? Oh, it absolutely is.
Yes. This is this is a core piece of the the of the lawsuit is
that H3 Snark and Denims coordinated. This is proof they coordinated.
Oh, sorry. No, the proof they coordinated was that Denims had
a link to Snark up or something later on. And honestly, so I
just want you to see when he starts his Denim section, what does
he put up? Take a look at this guys. It's a nightmare on Denim
Street. Not only did she cherry react, but she was kind enough
to write her name right at Wait, what did she chair react to?
Ethan, you're gonna say it, right? Just so that we knew that
she Also, he might say it. I actually didn't watch for stealing
my content and it was her room and nobody else's. Judge, did
you know that we're on Denim's street right now? Here's some
quotes from Denims. We're relying Oh, so he doesn't he he doesn't
he just tries to make it look exactly like this, right? On you
to stay live so we don't have to give the nuke views. Yeah, I'm
gonna stream it since he's confirmed. Just so we're clear.
Wait, he did say what? Wait, what did he say? And honestly, just
take a look at this, guys. It's a nightmare on Denim Street.
Not only did she chair react, but she was kind enough to write
her name right at the top just so that we knew that she was stealing
my content and it was her room and nobody else's. Judge, did
you know that we're on Denim? Wait, where did he say it? What
I'm looking for him to say is that this is not him suing her
for cherry reacting to the content nuke. That is what he tries
to make it seem like. And my whole point here is that like this
think that there's no transformative content or no transformative
commentary from from Denim's reaction, but there is a ton of
it. And this cherry action is not from her doing the content
nuke, right? That cherry act that was not the content nuke, but
he represented that way. I think yesterday or two days ago, I
was confused. But I thought maybe the reason why he brought the
um countdown stream, why he like listed that and then is invoking
that with the denims react was so he could subpoena the subreddit.
But I think the point that you and Kimma made was the idea that
her reaction to the content nuke was actually transformative
enough and that's why he's invoked the countdown stream beforehand
because she did minimal reaction to that. Yeah. So this whole
chair thing, this is it's
contrast and actually contradicts the reason why he had to bring
in that
stream. Well, it explains it. It I think it explains why he had
to bring that in or why he is bringing it in. Yeah. Yeah. But
the fact that he's pointing us to an empty chair while she was
reacting to the content nuke is really dishonest when he knows
that there was probably uh enough transformative engagement in
that reaction. That's why he has to hyperfocus on this one empty
chair. Right. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Um, so the implication
so he thinks No, he can win the court case, Hold on, Rhox. No,
no, no. He can win the court case against anybody. He could win
the court case against
uh me. He could win the court case against Queman. He could win
the court case against basically anyone. His the only thing he's
trying to say he's so what he has said is I won't go after anybody
who's done a sufficiently transformative reaction. Right? That's
what he said. I don't want to go after those people. But he is
going after those people because he is going after Denims in
a case where she is doing a very transformative reaction, right?
I think probably if you're reacting to a full content piece that's
like an hour and a half, hour and 50 minutes long, you're probably
always falling outside of fair use. Okay, basically always. You
have to get to the point where you're like um where you're like
EAP to even have an argument, right? Nobody does that. That is
not what the current climate is. But Ethan has stated he doesn't
want to go after people who do quote unquote transformative reactions.
He doesn't want to go after people who critically engage, who
do actual commentary. But he has done it and he's lied to people.
Okay? He is lying when he says he doesn't want to go after those
people because he is going after Denims and using a stream. He's
going after her with a stream where she is actually adding transformative
commentary
far more than anybody else. Exactly. But if you post this picture
of a chair, then his like two IQ like supporters who literally
just hate Denim, that's all they need to cling on to this and
be like, "Yeah, she wasn't transformative." Cuz they won't look
further. They don't care to look further. And he knows that this
will satisfy them. And that they will shamelessly just hold on
to this photo and be like, "Yeah, no, this is not reacting um
transformatively."
Well, and that's Yeah. Again, I'll just drive home. That's my
point is I've I've seen so many H3 sucks who have no idea that
Denims gave a ton of commentary on top of this video. They have
no concept. They don't understand it at all. They're all like,
"No, no, no. She didn't do anything substantial whatsoever."
That's not even the argument Ethan makes. The argument Ethan
makes in the lawsuit is that her commentary is like bad. No,
she gave bad commentary. That's why it's not real. Uh if he dropped
the denim suit and kept the other ones, should we suddenly start
cheering? No. But this is egregious. That's the problem. This
is egregious, right? I still think he's doing it only to bully
them. I think that's embarrassing because we all had a whole
understanding. Everybody had an understanding of how the system
worked, right? I think it's embarrassing that he operates outside
of that. That he's now trying to like basically call the teacher
on everybody that he's like trying to pull the cops over, pull
the law in because he can't win talking [__] I think
the only way that he satisfies um the majority of the people
uh criticizing him is if he just stands up and says, "All right,
I'm going after these three women because uh them. I don't like
them. Haven't liked them. And even though I set up to go after
them before they did any of the um CPS, it's just them forever."
Yeah. Um Yeah. It's them forever. And it like And I've seen a
whole bunch of people It's really important that you highlight
it again. highlight that again because I've seen a bunch of people
say, "Well, he went after his kids. What wouldn't you do to people
who went after their kids, your kids?" It's like, "No, he planned
this way before he went after uh way before anybody went after
his kids." Yeah, that's exactly what it is, Rhox. And that he
is trying to take a moral high ground. He's trying to represent
this in a certain way and he's saying that he's not doing things
that he's clearly doing. He says, "I'm not going after XQC or
other people because he didn't maliciously react. And I'm not
I I'm totally for He says, I'm totally for people who engage
and who actually make commentary, right? who try to engage and
they're watching and they actually comment on the stuff, right?
I'm totally for that. Denims did that. He is still suing Denims
for that reaction. He is still putting that under the court's
like eye and I think he can win on that because I think probably
all react content is essentially illegal. Is essentially like
violating fair use. I think more or less any React content to
like a content piece, like an edited content piece that's an
hour or so long. I think that's basically all illegal. the whole
thing. What I also Ethan says he doesn't want to go ahead. No,
can you finish your thought? Sure. Ethan says he doesn't want
to go after those people, but he is in fact actually going after
those people. Okay. What I would like to know is the over the
dates in which he
um registered the countdown stream. What day did he decide to
register the countdown stream? And what day did the CPS drama
happen? Because as much as I don't think that you can blame the
streamer for the chat or the unhinged antipans that Ethan has,
um, you obviously can be upset about it. You obviously can dislike
a streamer for like the audience that they pander to. You can't
literally blame them for calling CPS on you if they didn't actually
do a call to action. But it's not like it's not like I think
Ethan is soy or anything like that for being so upset that CPS
was called on him. I just think he has such a bad habit of maybe
not even maybe it's intentional of just like finding a person
that he can blame. Do we know what day he registered the the
stream and what day that stuff happened? Oh, we was registered
after No, we totally could figure that out. I want to say I want
to say February 28th. And when was CPS cuz it was like the last
week of February, right? The CPS call. Ethan Klein CPS items
and finally
It is true that the CPS stuff happened after he had registered
the content nuke. But if after the CPS stuff he decides to register
the uh the countdown stream, then maybe there's like a little
bit of a link there, right? A little bit of a cause and effect.
Exactly. Yes. I Well, I think it points to it for sure. Give
me a second. I'm looking up um I'm looking up the content nuke
thing. I'm just looking up on the the site here. Content nuke.
Hassan Ted Entertainment. T Entertainment.
Let's see when he loads these up. So, I think it's Countdown
to Doomsday, right? That's the one. Countdown to Doomsday. This
is on March 31st. Actually, March 31st. So far after CPS. Yes.
Long after CPS.
And it is very possible that when he was going over how people
reacted to the content nuke that Denims was not on the list of
people and
after the CPS thing he maybe was shuffling and looking for a
way to get her on that list. Uh possible. Yeah, it is definitely
possible. Um so a whole bunch of people are said a bunch of really
things in chat. Let me go back and see if I can find them now.
Um don't do copyright infringement while actively stating your
Oh, sure. Sides. This guy is uh prolifically. Yes, I don't blame
Denims for doing this because Ethan has said he doesn't want
to go after these things and he's gone after them. I hold him
to his words. He doesn't get to say, "Oh, I don't want to attack
all these people who like I kind of like and then go after them
completely." And then I go, "Oh, it's okay. Denims did this to
you." No, you're an adult with agency. You said you weren't going
after these people, but you clearly are. So, if you're going
to do that, if you're going to be a like this, go after XQC.
Don't that go after XQC. Okay, you are you are jeopardizing everybody
else and that's fine if you believe it principally, but go after
XQC.
Stand up to your stand up for your principles. Don't be a [__]
Yeah, but at the same time, like how how stupid are you to play
into the thing that makes you look like a like you're stealing
content and trying to hurt someone's income?
What did you say at the beginning?
How stupid are you to actually say things? Thank you. For stealing
people and then saying that you're doing it. Yes. By the way,
also we should we should make it very clear everyone for different
reasons. They they suck so badly for doing that. That is the
most You don't do that on like moral grounds. You don't do that
because you're a content creator. How are you going to live or
how are you going to like uh make your living if you if you support
people doing that to other creators? You are so stupid for doing
it, right? You're a total piece of denims, Caseyron, Froggen,
all major pieces of in my opinion for doing that at all. I don't
do that to people I really dislike.
I will I will hate somebody and I'll roll that back a couple
minutes and say if you want to watch live, go watch them, right?
Cuz it's it's like it feels like you have to uphold that because
you have to think of if everybody did this, is that okay? Hey,
is that a world I want to live in? No, it's obviously not. Will
Ethan's lawsuit negatively impact the community commentary community?
I think we don't know, but it could easily.
Yeah. So, I have like total condemnation for Denims and Frogan
and Casey participating in this and crowing about it. Um, yeah.
I have I have total condemnation for it. I I think it's like
a complete piece of thing to do. I just wish we weren't bringing
legality into it because I think that's silly.
Yeah, because it is going to be the combination. It's going to
be
I don't see how either side doesn't have some sort of reputation
hit for this. Ethan for escalating to where it is and then the
the women for probably just being just being the absolute worst
to cause somebody to go after them in this way, right? You couldn't
smile. Just want No, I'm just kidding. But you know what I mean?
Like to be so You also put everyone at risk.
Yeah. No, they're total pieces of Yep. That's why when Asmin
Gold was looking at it, he's like, "No, you're up my because
he knows, okay, she's going to be the perfect villain to be able
to squash React content, right? Cuz she does look egregious.
She does look malicious." And so anybody else not like seeing
the context around it or seeing how how like normal it is to
banter and talk [__] while you're doing something
like this, like yeah, this just looks looks like a problem that
needs to go away. Stop this react content.
Yep. And
yeah, exactly. I feel like we're I I need somebody to disagree
with Cherry because we've just been locked step on this the whole
way. Well, also we were talking about it before, so that's probably
a little disingenuous. Uh Ryan asked if we've seen this. Copy
my entire take. Like, oh, Cherry, what do you think? Not the
entire thing. Not the entire thing. Oh, man. I completely agree
with Cherry. I need someone I disagree with. I don't I don't
just copy Cherry. That's not true. That's not true. I also steal
from other people.
Okay. What is this? Ethan reacts to an edit of Denim's implying
he was never going to sue. Grimacing.
I think what did Denim say he wasn't going to sue over? Defamation.
I think it was the defamation thing. How's the lawsuit going?
Uh, nowhere because Ethan Klein's too much of a sue me cuz he
knows. Yeah, Kelly, we're doing calls tonight. I already told
you that. You You know that. Lose. I love these people though
that are like April 5th, 2025. I wonder why she'd be talking
about the content nuke which he reacted to almost what two sorry
that we go back to March then February almost two full months
earlier sorry more than two full months earlier that she'd reacted
to the content nuke. Why is she saying oh he won't sue me in
a on April 5th 2025. Do you guys think that might have something
to do with CPS? Are we totally misrepresenting what's actually
going on here? Any day now. Any day now he's going to sue. He's
going to sue. Chad, just a reminder by the way. Just a reminder,
after he paraded on the internet about how he was going to sue
me and he wanted to sue me, guess what? Still no lawsuit. Oh
my god, he's so made. I'm actually pretty certain that he actually
his lawyer told him to stop going after me. His lawyer most likely
said, "Dude, like you like need to stop. Like you actually need
to stop." Whatever you think I Yeah, that's probably true. Wait,
that's actually probably true. uh him being able to sue for this
is totally different than him being able to sue for defamation
or continue to say that Denims like did the CPS thing, right?
Obviously, I'm the dumbest person alive. That's fine. Go read
the lawsuit. Maybe if you don't want to respect me, you can go
respect a judge and a lawyer.
How's the lawsuit going? This is like we'll we'll just edit this
in any way we possibly can to make Denims look bad. Very sad.
Very sad. Very sad.
She called him made. Oh well, there's at least one piece of uh
commentary she's given. That is true. He is [__]
Thank god. Okay. I have a such a hard time agreeing with anything
Denim said says, she's so Almost every time I listen to her,
but if she just says Ethan Klein's [__] made, that
is actually true. Let's go.
She got one right. Ah, it's awesome. Okay, videos. Oh, yes. Yes.
This per this person. I went on the whole thing about it not
being transformed because of this person. Jesus. Okay, I have
to start like focusing and reading. I am willing to bet arguments
get made explaining the nature of the space. Mentioning them
creates a reasonable expectation of reaction. Ethan Hassan/Ethan
being prominent figures warrants reaction that these circumstances
and Ethan's admitted copyright misuse nullifies the rest. I don't
know if that will be so it is a strict liability thing, but I
think the reason that they included the the H3 snark sub is to
make the liability as large as they can, right? And I don't know
that you can get denims on any of the H3 snark link links in
or the Hassan links in. I think I think there's going to be a
lot of people going actually just there's going to be a lot of
evidence given uh between Hassan's discord between H3 Stark and
no evidence of Denim's colluding with them directly. There's
going to be a lot of evidence I think that she was not really
responsible for the 48,000 viewers. She's responsible for like
3,000 viewers tops. Really? I thought that including that was
so he can just find the the names and the identities of more
people. could also be he hates. Yeah, it could also be to to
subpoena them as well. Yeah, it it definitely could. So, what
is liking liking goes on? Also, who knows how this plays out,
but I wish people would at least be honest and quit pretending
they actually care about the validity of the claim. If any of
you did the same, you would be making the same arguments I am.
Like, I I do think this is totally sidescopyright
misuse. Your argument hinges on I don't think there's misuse
here. like it's different, right? I think it's like a it's an
easy moral argument to make. I don't know if it matters for copyright
infringement, right? It's like basically
uh it's what's happening, okay, is you just watched
you just watched 12 of your friends a 16-year-old, okay, in the
state of California where it's statuto and then you did it after
those 12 people did and then the state only prosecutes you.
And then it's like, but but I thought it was I thought it was
okay. I thought it was okay. And then the thing goes, actually
strict
Can you just go back to stealing my like opinions and my analogies?
Uh, sorry. I I have only so many strict liability crimes that
I know about and statutory is one of them. Right. Where it's
like and it's like, okay. Right. I don't know. Why is that one
that you know? The whole point was morally there's probably some
reason, okay, that you thought that that was okay. there's probably
some reason and maybe and basically there it's like okay there's
probably morally some reason but it doesn't help you right so
in this case I think there is like a moral thing where we should
expect Denim to respond where Ethan had participated in a world
where she could respond and then because it's a strict liability
crime and her intention and everything doesn't matter now now
he probably has a case it's it's weird serving alcohol to minors
let's go yeah or do the do the speeding one like anything else
serving alcohol Oh, the minor is probably a good one, but I'm
just saying that like basically there's like somewhere where
you you be you understood this a part of the culture and then
you got reported and you're the only person who's getting reported
and it feels annoying. Anyway, continuing on. There's no copyright
misuse. Your argument hinges on misrepresenting Ethan's actions.
He has every right to copyright his own creative work. Doing
so with the knowledge that someone might try to steal it does
not equal misuse. Actually, I think and I think if they if Denims
does actually go through this lawsuit and they enter Discovery,
I sure hope I sure hope she decides to suspena emails with one
with a person who I used to stream with fairly often. Okay? Cuz
I would love to see if it wasn't suggested to Ethan, hey, you
could really these people by copyrighting in this way. I'd want
to know if that if that suggestion was made. Another reason why
other people who are not named or being sued right now should
be concerned. This is like the um I'm in love with somebody who
is just in a really toxic relationship and I'm just going to
like support them because I believe them and they're the one
that I know. This is how he's going to treat everybody eventually.
Right? If he's not targeting you now, wait till he's bigger than
you or wait till he feels like you've crossed him in a certain
way and then you will be targeted like this. That's why you judge
people. That's why you criticize people for behaving like this.
You don't just say, "Yeah, I don't like this person either."
So anything goes against them. Yeah. Uh that's I don't understand
how people operate without doing that. Like hey, here's the thing
that's happening. If the situations were reversed and it was
happening in complete reverse order, would I would I actually
support that? No, I wouldn't. It's easier said than done. That's
why going after such hatable women is like a strategy and reminding
them how hateable they are because you just want everyone to
believe that like you're in the
It's it's effective. It works. It shouldn't, but as you can see,
harder for people to support denims than to just like choose
to not say anything.
It works perfectly every time and it's very sad.
Oh, did actually influence the CPS call? Yeah. No, I've got all
those clips here, Space Ghost. I've got all these clips. Um,
we can go over all of them. I just need to make it through this
thread because I had one point I was trying to make and now I
think we've gotten our but we've gotten our takes out and well,
I think it it sucks because it doesn't suck. It's actually good.
Um cuz we're getting our takes out on the table and this thread
is helping to demonstrate. It's actually good. I just thought
I was going to get through it faster, but yes, there is black.
I'm like the only person in the world that gets so annoyed when
like this stream where you want to have a co-host and interact
and talk and uh like you get annoyed that oh look at us we've
like two hours interacting and talking. Uh I think we actually
building viewership. I think it's very entertaining. I'm just
that's how I see you act annoyed.
Yeah, I'm not really annoyed. Yeah, I'm not really annoyed. I'm
Canadian. I apologize for everything. I go, "Oh, I can't believe
we're doing this. It's just being Canadian."
And for that, Cherry,
I'm sorry. Good times. Good times. Okay. All right. So, where
were we here? So, like in response to this guy as a non lawyer,
but someone with Google and a semi-functioning brain, it seems
Laser Comb America Inc. versus Reynolds, Jacobson, and Catser
and Video Pipeline. So, he lists these two things. Uh, are three
cases that have had rulings that use copyright outside of the
scope of the law's intent to protect IP are misuse. So, if the
defense successfully argues Ethan's comments in the video shown
intent to misuse, yeah, I think his case is pretty weak. His
selective enforcement lawsuits against people he's beefed with
will probably trigger the defense to also use bad faith enforcement
rulings as well, which there are plenty of it, or plenty of,
it seems. This all hinges on Ethan's own words in his own video,
not on a misinterpretation of any action except his selective
targeting. The latter isn't even necessary to form to uphold
uh for the former to uphold my theory and the rest. He can copyright
his work all he wants, but he himself said he laid a trap and
created something he knew these people couldn't help but watch.
Courts seem to be really careful when taking rules in favor of
implied license when taking ruling in fa sorry when talking ruling
in favor of implied license. But I'm finding a lot of case law
supporting it. Estate v or estate of Heavia v Hortrio court.
The court ruled implied license depends on objective manifestations
of intent. So his words may bite him in the ass there too. Sorry
if you disagree with me. Sorry, you can disagree with me all
you want, but you're deluding yourself if you think this is a
clear-cut win for Ethan after this video. Uh instead of doing
goo instead of using Google. So I think this is kind of where
my head would be at. So it's good to know that other people have
argued it. I don't know how successfully they've how successful
they've been with it. Guys, I I know that Trump bombed the nuclear
sites. We covered it. Um yeah, we covered it. I unfortunately
this Ethan Klein stuff is just way more interesting to me than
than the US being the lap dog of Israel again. Okay, the US being
the lap dog of Israel, we can cover that every single day of
the week for the next 5 years and we'll never run out of content.
This stuff, okay, this stuff, Ethan Klein filing these lawsuits
and the bullet from it, that's right now. That's just now. Okay.
Also, but unfortunately Ethan Hassan Destiny content we can probably
cover forever as well, but right now this is what I'm interested
in. Okay. Instead of using Google Yeah. Yeah. Do me a favor and
try to actually try actually using your brain. What I'm suggesting
isn't difficult or complex. He didn't force Denim's Oh, this
person is actually just not engaging with the argument at all.
Cool. I didn't didn't force them to steal his content. He didn't
even bait them into it. He simply decided to copyright his video
with the knowledge that they were likely to steal it. That's
not true. He said he wanted to create a trap. He said he was
doing it to bait them, right? He didn't say they were going to
bait steal it no matter what. He said, I created a piece of content
that was so juicy they'd have to react. That's that's him talking
about I want them to react to this so I can sue them. That's
his and he's stating it, right? He's stating that that's his
mental like that is his mind state. You could never prove that,
right? You could literally never prove that in a million years,
but he went out of his way to say it in a video. It's possible
to react in a lawful way. That's what Denims did. That's what
Denims did to the video. Uh, it's also not selective enforcement.
He quite clearly explained the criteria behind the people he's
focusing on. All three of them outright admitted that they are
intentionally using their streams to siphon views away from Ethan's
video. This was the logical basis behind him suing them. Specifically,
no judge with even a modicum of critical thought is going to
include
that if you sue someone for defaming you that you may must also
sue everyone else who has ever defamed you or you're unfairly
targeting someone. I think the issue here is that he's selected
somebody and yeah, he's he's given his criteria, but I don't
know exactly how copyright law. This is the other thing. I've
got to maybe talk to Pisco or something about this. Uh I don't
know how how enforcing your copyrights or trademarks works cuz
I think there are cases if you identify clear cases of people
stealing your IP and you don't defend them, I think that does
create some issues for you. I think it actually does. Yeah. Uh
I answered this above, but you only replied to the second half.
I'm willing to bet arguments get made. explain the nature of
the space. Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Play to everything you said.
Again, your argument hinges on false declaration that he's misusing
copyright. You're ignoring my counterargument.
Uh, where I Okay, I don't know if any of this is actually important.
His own original content/creation.
He has every right to copyright this work. I don't know about
that. That could probably be argued, too. Copyright is entirely
Oh, trademarks you have to defend. Okay. Okay, got it. Yes, it
can create an argument for the waiver of the copyright or implied
consent. Well, I I think that so the implied license thing is
something that does get argued and I think the implied license
argument for this is fairly strong to be honest. I do believe
it is fairly strong that they had back back and forths multiple
times. Nobody sued each other, right? I think there is a very
strong implied license argument here that that should be able
to get used. Knowing they might steal it is not the same as hoping
they do. I laid a trap and I created something I knew they couldn't
resist reacting to. Yeah, exactly. I implore you to stop using
Google forever. It is fragged your ability to form critical original
thoughts. Like I don't understand this. When when you have to
respond with an insult instead of just to the argument, it tells
me that you know you're losing the argument, right? Like if you
have to respond with an insult, I I'm just going to say you're
probably losing. I say that as somebody who likes responding
with insults. So um whether or not I'm winning, but I I'll say
most of the time when I'm reading it, if you're just throwing
out insults instead of responding to the argument, I do think
you're losing. I say that as somebody who does that when I think
I'm winning. Uh, if I hope someone punches me and they punch
me, I still have the right to defend myself. There's not a judge.
Hold on. But that's not what Hold on. Do you see how sneaky it
is? Do you see how sneaky this loser is? Okay. If I If I hope
someone punches me and they punch me, I still have the right
to defend myself. But if you literally write in your blog or
your journal or something, you literally say, "I'm going to get
this guy to punch me. I think I can figure out how to get him
to punch me." And then you go and say something to him, planning
for him to punch you. And then you get punched in the face. It's
hard not to read that plan, even if it is something that could
happen or would be reasonable in the moment. It's hard not to
read that as some kind of incitement. It just is. Uh there's
not a judge on planet Earth who is going to claim that they had
the right to steal his content viewership simply because he hoped
they would. It if it is decided that they deliberately stole
his content, they will lose their lawsuit. I think there is an
implied license thing here that could go on, but he literally
said he set the trap, dumbass. Those were his words. He set a
trap in the same way that someone installing a security camera
sets a trap for burglars. It means nothing in the context of
what happened. Uh but also like he would have been participating
in something that is akin to burglary himself and he would have
let other people burgle him in similar ways consistently. Right?
That's the problem is like he set up a security camera and he
he literally created a culture of this back and forth burgling
and then once he had the people who he didn't like who burgled
him, he went, "I got you. I got you. I got you." That's what
makes it weird. Now, he set the trap in the same way that cops
put a baked car in a high crime neighborhood to boost up their
arrest stats because it serves no purpose for actually improving
security in the neighborhood. It just gives them an easy arrest.
This is the dumbest I've ever read in my life. I don't think
so. Dumbest I've ever read in my life. Now you know why I'm mad
at you for replacing critical thought with Google. Arresting
criminals does in fact improve the security of an area. Okay,
this person this person would I feel like this person would have
a lot of different comments on um Oh man, what aren't you just
behind or aren't you just like totally fine with stop and frisk
and and the way like New York City used to enforce drug laws
that like predominantly targeted black people? It's like, hey,
they banned weed on them. That that's against the law. Aren't
you just totally for that? Like, hey, it's against the law. Oh,
how does how does taking that person off the street not like
reduce criminality? Anyway, uh let's take the this one at a time.
Arresting violent criminal improves security. Arresting low-level
criminals, like someone who would break into a car and steal
something does not. Those types of arrests actively harm communities.
This is born out of borne out in too much data for you to say
silly things like this. So, this is an argument that conservatives
would make. Yes. Sorry, this person's making the argument and
like doing the progressive one. I don't totally agree with it.
Okay. But he is making the conservative argument. What? What?
What? So the idea is you go to a low-income neighborhood and
you put like expensive a car knowing people will go steal it.
Yes, those people are down on their luck. They will break into
a car and steal like a watch sitting there, right? Oh my god.
They will do that in low income areas. You almost don't even
need to set them up, right? Like there's just high crime in lowincome
areas. And it's actually even the people who live in those lowincome
areas that would like the police to do something to address the
crime. Yeah, sure. I'm just Yes. Exactly. But I'm saying that
there is something there where it's like, is that a good use
of resources? What are you doing there? I again, I don't make
these arguments. I don't make this exact argument. This is like
a progressive argument that I I'm not a huge fan of. Yes. Anyway,
because he is a soyic leftist. Sorry,
a little bit. He is a little bit. Okay, that finally brings me
to uh Oh, my whole point here for for doing this whole thing.
One second. Which was just to pull um what was it? Was it this
one? Somebody was waiting for him to make like a B. Oh, whoops.
Not that one. This one. Somebody was waiting for him to just
make a goofy argument. Okay. So that they could try to make their
own points. Where is it? Here. Where is it? Am I missing it?
Breaking into cars is a low-level offense. I unfollowed and blocked.
End of an era. Okay. So, Lyan did end up making those arguments.
Go ahead. Actually, no. Never mind. I don't care. Oh, are you
sure? Yeah. Just this loser is going to say something like, "Oh,
if somebody broke my car and stole my saxophone while I was in
college, I was dumb." Yeah, exactly. Um I'm I'm sure there are
a lot of things here. I just think it's very funny that uh Destiny's
got to go after Lyk and his straight raid right now and it's
so transparent what's actually going on. Straight raid is streaming
and talking to Pisco and that feels very threatening to somebody
who people have disavowed. Okay, that feels very wrong. Uh-oh.
Guys, it's really it's really rough that straight raid and Lykan
and all these people who like were critical of me, they're they're
like collaborating now and I don't like that. So I have to I
have to point out to my community that like and straight raid
are bad. They're bad guys. They're bad. Don't you know how bad
they are? Really? I think so. Yes. That is how I see it entirely
because there's no reason for So where do we start off here?
We start off with my tweet. Okay. This we're going to get a little
skitso here. Okay. Wait, before you go down your skitso tree
that Dan saying I unfollowed end of an era. Like Dan wanted him
gone since what was he was like producing for anything else.
Like Dan didn't even like if that guy talked during their podcast.
I'm pretty
like like a while. But okay. Dan was not nice to like in that
shirt. That's true. That's true. Uh not this one. What are we
looking Oh, is gen chat still locked? You guys didn't hit 30
likes on that. That's rough. It was rough for you guys. So this
is the one we're looking at. So, we had this thread as well where
Pisco's arguing with people and uh Pisco's arguing with Dan.
Okay, because I'll we'll actually go back through this whole
thing, too. But this was the thing that annoyed me is somebody
responds to Pisco and says, "Are you really pretending that Lykan
is straighter raid aren't the reason why you have all this heat
for Ethan? Lol. Crazy projection." What? Pisco was against Dan
for the Dan Saltman was against Dan Saltman when it seemed like
they were trying to go after
uh Twitch channel or whatever trying to affect um advertising
because of Hassan, right? Pitco is just never
Yeah, you know, he's got principles. I guess he is just principled
and he's also the funny thing is is this is just like downstream
of oh straight raid straight raid influences all these people.
It's like
at some point I'm going to start making jokes about like the
straight raid, okay? That like people just conspire that straight
raid's like controlling all of these people's minds. It's so
stupid. Like I don't I don't understand. He kind of has principles.
I just real quick I have to correct that he kind of has principles.
He did say that Biden was the best president of his lifetime.
And I will I'll never forget that. But everything else he seems
okay. Yeah. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That's uh that's your Sure.
Um, all right. Okay, we got that locked up now on this stuff.
Okay, on on stuff he's gonna, how should I put it? On stuff where
he's already disagreed with a lot of the people that certain
people wouldn't want him to disagree with, he's going to stay
principled. He's he's decided that that's where he's principled.
And this was what some place, right, where he was against like
the whole anti- Twitch anti-mitism thing from the beginning.
This is one of those places where he is going to maintain his
principles, right? Also, also, yes, I have to use the bathroom
so badly. I'm trying to think of a way to segue into that. I'll
be right back. Give me two seconds. Um, other things. So, I would
say that Pisco has his opinions, but he also has somebody that
he's dating or talking to, and I imagine many conversations between
the two of two of them uh contributes to why he also supports
what is that country? Palestine.
Palestine. If anybody thinks I know what's going on in this conflict,
I don't. But yeah, to to imagine that another woman and her boyfriend
are the reason why Bisco is thinking the way that he is. Like,
can we just be full-blown misogynist and actually blame like
his girlfriend? It's pretty up. If I was his girlfriend, I would
want people to think that I am the one who might him, not some
other woman.
I actually don't think I'm making this better. I think I'm might
be pointing people in the direction of another woman to blame
for this that I'm trying. This is me. The house is on fire and
I'm like, I'm helping. Okay, I'm back. Uh, welcome back. Yeah,
here here it is. Here's um Destiny was talking about this in
what do you call it like his logs as well like/ Aaron side with
denims on Israel Palestine. So they'll side against H3H3 on everything
and it's like no this people can be against these lawsuits. I
you could actually have it. So I could and this is me. I fully
think Ethan will win every one of these lawsuits. That's what
I think, right? But I just think they're wrong to do anyway,
especially given his state of goals. I think he's going to out
I think it's going to be a I think he's going to um pull back.
I think he won't actually effectively bankrupt any of them and
I think he will forever be cemented as a [__] because
of it. He's a [__] either way. Ethan lose lose for
you pursuing them. You're pursuing them in the first place and
you're going to be a for not bankrupting them. There's no way
out. There's no way out of the coffin you've made, Ethan. Okay.
No way out. No way out. I didn't. We did not put you in this
situation. Somebody else gay opted you into doing this knowing
that you can't win. Who Who are you helping out right now? I
wonder if Ethan's wondering that. Who are you helping? Who's
Who's taking zero heat? Who's totally just sitting in the background?
Also, this tweet appropo of nothing from 30 minutes ago. What
could he possibly be talking about? What could he possibly be
talking about? I actually I don't know what gay op means. So,
if somebody could let me know if I'm using it wrong.
Um, Ronald asked if I because I do have that in my in my here.
I just want to go through and like um I just listen I just like
taking shots at Destiny when he's like clearly trying to once
again shape opinion of people who want nothing to do with him.
Okay. Off. They don't like you. They don't like you little bro.
Okay. Off. But he'll do he'll do these gay little comments all
the time. Um
here this is the this is the other one. I don't know if I agree.
I don't know if Destiny's been watching our He probably has on
the Ethan Klein stuff, right? But he just does he does like these
stupid comments. Oh, hold on, hold on, no. Oh, hold on. Destiny,
if you were watching this stream, I don't even know who this
guy is. I don't support this stream. I don't even like it here.
True. Broken record. People's political views influence how they
view every single thing related to a person so much. or their
personal relationship with somebody like watching Justical and
Quean contort themselves into knots to try to defend Idubbbz
and on Ethan just because uh I think I said all of Idubbbz's
video was awful. I think I think I said Idubbbz totally embarrassed
himself and we laughed at him the whole time. Why is he pretending
that we supported Idubbbz? What? How in the world could you possibly
Amazing. They know that like I'm on Ethan's side. It was just
insane. and then watching um I think I've seen this again just
totally making up again right just entirely
just whole cloth fabricating what was actually said no shame
no embarrassment and like it now are like trying to argue that
oh here we go denims and frogen all them did nothing wrong but
it's just because of the I don't think I don't think listen I
have not seen straight stream on this yet but I just I significantly
doubt or severely doubt that either of them are saying nothing
wrong was done right. Destiny has always been very anti. Remember
when Destiny lost his mind because Matt Walsh DMC him for covering
his payto- view documentary on his stream and he like lost his
about it. It absolutely happened. Yes. Wait, was that that was
Lady Ballers? No, no, no. Not Lady. What is a woman? What is
a woman? He watched it with Far. He reacted to that with Far.
Right. Right. Yeah.
and and he totally lost his this person has no principles and
they're just totally mogged by Pisco in every way. At least Pisco
can keep his principles straight. Okay. Uh does Destiny not hear
all the Hassan is bad? He does not. He doesn't hear them at all.
Yeah. So I This is how I knew okay that I was going to get more
DJs in like Lyans comments and stuff making like talking all
over the place. his destiny had to go out and and talk them like
trying to argue that Denims and Frog and all them did nothing
wrong, but it's just because of their position on the Israel
Palestine stuff and it's like Jesus. Okay, I'm saying that like
if you agree with somebody or disagree with somebody on like
some I wonder if them being on the other side of that issue and
not being like totally enthralled to Ethan Klein has something
to do with them going, "Hey, chilling criticism via via litigation
is wrong." Which, by the way, Ethan had fantasized about suing
them when he when he signed up for this copyright thing. It wasn't
like he saw them react and then he went, "Oh, I have to do extra
copyright protections." He made the video with the intention
of getting them to react in their lazy way so that he could sue
them, right? That's what he was jerking off to, that he was criticized
and he was mad about that and then he decided to do this. Now,
could that have happened without them also being Probably not.
But I'm telling you that that was that was what Ethan was doing.
He has and he's done it to other people in less beneficial to
him circumstances with the Noah Samson thing, right? He did it
with the Noah Samson thing where he had somebody criticizing
him and he tried to chill that via litigation. He's a loser.
He's a crybully loser. Personalism policy think like they'll
defend every single they feel like they have to go to the extreme
and defend every single thing that person does. It just seems
like really wacky to me. Like if Denim's uh by the way this applies
to nobody, but again we already said here going and setting up
to reream somebody's content and say that you're psych that you're
taking away views for them is psychopathic. It's so annoying.
It's so gross. Okay. I just don't think you should be sued for
it as like a primary method of dealing with it. That's nuts.
Stab somebody and be like, "Well, you know, she's I don't know.
It just feels like people would defend him, but they sure the
political view or something." I just feels wacky to me. Whatever.
They outright say they are sampling your income. Yeah. I I'm
telling you that's like dog. It's total dog. See, Johnny Combo
is one of the total
totally
losers who hasn't looked at Denim's reaction and just says, "Be
transformative. Get sued. Leech. Denims is a 100 times more transformative
with that content than XQC is. You You can't say this. You, Johnny
combo, you have to feel very embarrassed for your comment right
there, right? You have to feel very embarrassed for how stupid
you are and how proudly and arrogantly stupid you are in this
chat. Okay. Okay. Johnny Combo, why is Denim's stuff not transformative?
Explain to me why Denim's uh reaction to the content nuke was
not transformative.
You have to say transform transformative to Ethan's standard
because otherwise they're going to get you on a debate pervert
technicality. Well, actually all react content is not transformative.
I didn't think it was standard. That was your response. Uh you're
you're actually saying I don't care. I'm I'm only pretending
to be repeatedly. Come back in a day. Come back in a day. Bold
move to alienate the H3 community as well as the DG. I'm just
going to I'm just going to say the things I think are correct.
That's what the stream is. That's what it is. I'm sorry. That
is just what it is. I don't give a [__] It should
be an instant timeout. It should. Yes.
You're arguing both that uh stealing uh both that stealing people
to hurt them is wrong. Stealing from people to hurt them. I think
and that using that exact law that see exists to seek satisfaction
for that exact offense is loser made behavior. Yes. I think Kelly
would like us to go to the other Discord if you want to do that.
If I want to do what?
To go to the other Discord so she can actually join today. Well,
I think we're going to take calls from people. This is why I
said she I I understand she doesn't want to join this Discord,
but I was going to let people call in. Also, yeah, that guy can
call in if he wants. Johnny combo, you want to call in?
Kelly trying to block Supreme. Kelly and Supreme can come on
at the same time if they want. Kelly just join, too. Sure. Um,
hold on. I'm just saying they might not know that the other server
that Kelly is in, Supreme, is also in it. It wouldn't be blocking.
Oh, one second. What do we do here?
one second. Can you fill for two seconds? I have to do something.
Okay. What is going on, you guys?
Apparently, Tommy C will be reacting to Chad Logic one argument
at a time every day or something. He's not reacting to the whole
stream. He's going to pick one thing that Chad said and he's
going to respond to it. So, we might have like three months of
react reacting to Tommy C content. We'll see.
Oh. Oh, Tommy. I did see that, too. Yeah, Tommy C. He's just
He's just going to farm. I think he also admitted that he just
got destroyed though. So, I mean, that's not so bad, right? When
he wants to full on admit that
that he full on wants to admit what?
That he lost. Like, it sounds like he was fully admitting he
lost. He knows he lost. Oh, did he? I didn't see that. Yeah,
I did see the part what you said, but then Riyle posted something.
We could maybe find Ry's tweet here real quick. Oh, that. No,
he said he was tapping out. He said only on request. He was very
clearly tapping. Oh, okay. He's tapping out. Gotcha. Okay. Well,
damn. He I think he No, he said the other thing first and then
I think he watched a little bit and realized that he was like
done. Got leaked cuz he pushed this point further later on. What
the is above this? Uh
oh. Oh, that's Casey Tron. Okay. I was told that apparently the
Aerodite react to the to the lawsuit is very good. So, we might
have to Maybe that'll be oiler content, guys, if we want to watch
the the Aerodite response
Did you see the Israeli super weapon used nine nuclear researchers?
No. No. Okay. Yeah, we might do this another call later. Tommy
C admits defeat. It appears the inter commentary war between
irrational Chad and Tommy CSFP is over. Tommy C concedes Chud
was correct on the timeline. Tommy C also manages to invent a
new critique. Chud roped Tommy C into uh roped Tommy C into content.
God forbid. But me, that's amazing. I I'm a content creator and
you've roped me into doing my job. Tried Logic has tricked me
into being somewhat entertaining. It's crazy. If that's an illusion
to the fact that his only fans got leaked, because he pushed
this point further later on that me talking about the dress picture
led to the only fans getting which I have conceded on. He's 100%
correct. He is 100% correct. I thought it did. Uh that wasn't
the right timeline. He came in. He's corrected me. But that's
still, even though I got that thought, it doesn't change the
point that you did this for, you know, I think you did this on
purpose to keep the content mill going. And considering yourself
audience captured, you'll DM me uh to to kind of rope us into
uh for content, you'll rope uh Willie into content and my allegation
that you use your friends for content. All right, here's where
he gets me. I misspoke here 100%.
I don't know for the time. And you know what? I'm gonna I'm just
gonna own it. I don't know if I was remember the timeline at
the time that I said this, right? So, he does kind of got me
here, but like I'll stick to this. Everybody Nobody knew for
100% sure he was running around wearing dresses. Misspoke. This
is I'll give Chad a point here, but it doesn't defeat the main
thrust. It does. I Tommy got totally destroyed on this. It's
It's over for Tommy.
Oh, it's totally over. Okay.
Now,
I think Okay, I've got all of that stuff out of the way. I kind
of I might want to go back and read that Pisco thread now. Pisco
and Dan arguing. I didn't actually see what this was about. Let's
uh let's just skip up and see if we can find this here. So,
so Pisco says on his on his timeline for the he didn't claim
he was a savior people. He is literally is claiming his lawsuits
are to protect the reaction community and to go after lazy reactors
while vindicating IP so that Sony and Disney don't end up suing
one day co-arter.
So he won and aristocracy says are you going to critique any
of the law they set forth in their an analysis
or are you just going to cavet about the introduction? Wait,
can she use that? When I say cavet, I'm I'm anti-semitic, but
when when she just gets to say it, she has to talk about kvetching.
The
um I think Pisco also did like a whole stream crit like critiquing
the legal document itself. I think he did a ton of critique of
the legal document.
I know reading comprehension isn't your strength, but I literally
state multiple times in my post and my video that I agree that
the videos are infringing. I say that it's probably not fair
use and that the complaint is likely not dismissible, but you're
too triggered. I get it. Ooh, he's such an [__]
You're triggered.
Um, he is kind of anal. Yeah, that's what he's known for. Did
you already go over the new nuclear happenings? Well, the nuclear
happenings was just I knew the US I'd seen a bunch of reporting
that the US was going to follow through on a strike, but I thought
it was going to be days from now and then we found out that they
actually struck, which kind of was anticlimactic a little bit,
right? They struck all the sites already. Like it's it's over.
I kind of I like the Israel Palestine stuff, but honestly, the
the actual like drama stuff is just better right now. So guys,
if you want to do Israel Palestine stuff, we will cover it eventually.
All right. Okay. Does aristocracy not respond to Pisco? She apparently
doesn't. But this gets into Dan's Oh, Dan quote tweets here.
Where's the Dan quote tweet?
Probably not fair use. Is it even possible to find a case that
would be more clear-cut? I think selling bootleg Avenger DVDs
on the street would be safer. At least it this that isn't done
with explicit malice on release day while publicly stating you
know it's illegal but yellow
um actually explicit malice doesn't matter here at all. That's
how he's going to Dan here, right? Explicit malice doesn't matter.
Statuto crime explicit explicit malice is like probably a good
sign or like might lead to Ethan suing them. But explicit malice
doesn't really matter in terms of how safe or unsafe the lawsuit
is. Probably not fair use is a correct statement. And in my stream
I use stronger language. That said, there are plenty of examples,
including bootlegging, which would be more clear-cut, not fair
use, regardless of how safe it is. Reposting an unedited copy,
also more clear. Uh, it's weasel. The matrix probably isn't real.
You probably can't shape shift into a dinosaur. The world probably
isn't filled with cheddar cheese, molten core. This case deserves
a stronger statement. There would suffice. Unhinged. It's not
a euphemism. It's a reflection of the inherent unpredictability
of lawsuits and fair use. Specifically, where we all where we
all go on.
Where all we go on. Sorry. All we go on are uh on really our
case law analogies. Sorry you were triggered. I didn't use your
magic words
Um hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What is the meme?
Pisco when Hassan says an unverifiable statement after already
being caught lying. I am 100% proven correct. Epic W victory
lab. Pisco in the world's most clear-cut case of infringement
is shown to him. Well, it's probably not fair use. I can't be
sure. Lawsuits are unpredictable. the denims one if she dude
the denims one is going to be a I think there's probably some
conflation of stuff where like Denim's basically doesn't really
doesn't really lose that if it goes to litigation I think I think
possibly I do think she if I had to guess if I had to bet money
I would bet on her losing for sure but I think there's some it's
like it's not like she just reproduced it or rereamed it with
no commentary right that is obviously worse uh and by the way
I believe the next day she says something along the lines of
people probably wanted to watch it with criticism implying She
obviously was criticizing it, right? So, my level of certainty
is probably consistent between the two cases. 99% infringement,
99% viewpoint discrimination. I'll defend both of those positions.
No inconsistency whatsoever. The viewpoint discrimination by
Trump makes me more passionate than the infringement, though
correct. It is such a self-report, excuse me. It is such a self-report
that you would compare these two situations because it shows
that for you, this is about people and clicks rather than the
underlying issues. What matters for you is the who and not the
what. Ethan versus Assan, not infringement versus VPD. uh viewpoint
discrimination.
So he's saying, "Oh, you this is just about the sides. If it
if it wasn't Ethan and Hassan, you wouldn't care about this at
all." And in fact, this is a fantastic point because I know Dan
knows, okay, everybody who's ever participated in in DGG knows
that they reream Hassan via other Twitch accounts so that they
don't have to watch Hassan's stream and give him views. And Destiny
explicitly supports that. Where is Dan coming out and saying
like, "That's the most obvious case of infringement. There's
a whole bunch of malice there, guys. These people are really
gross." All facilitated through Destiny's 5. No. No. Do we have
the same level of Yeah, we don't. Obviously, we don't.
Okay. All right. All right. I don't know if So, I'll finish this
one off and then we could maybe look at there's more. Apparently,
Pisco versus aristocracy over here. Okay. I don't have heat for
Ethan. I genuinely think he was a force for good for fair use
and in general has pushed a good standard. I was arguing harshly
against Lykan in my chat on the infringement, but because I criticized
one of the one of his stated purposes on the on defiling. Why
does he say duh defiling on defiling? Y'all lose your mind. What?
He does that sometimes. He just throws like random [__]
like that in. I have no idea where it comes from. Where did this
come from? Pisco
on defiling. Y'all lose your minds. Yes, you do. This heat is
so unjustified and weird and weird. It's so funny. RH3 fine with
owners suing to enforce IP against infringement. Even though
bad intent or malice uh legally/c colloquially are not elements,
they can justifiably be grounds to pick targets. But the React
Savior stuff is cringe and 100%. Also, complaint is dog. Yeah,
both of those are totally fine. But this is this is just 100%
legitimate, right? Uh the React Savior stuff is cringe as
the complaint is written. Why are you comparing Hassan to a guy
who shook hands with Hitler? Why what relevance does that have
to your complaint? Why the What are you doing?
Heat for Ethan. I take to be some uh to be like some dislike
of Ethan. I don't dislike Ethan. I was a longtime H3 fan and
watcher from Humongous to SL to Soflo Antonio to vape God, etc.
But what but if what you mean is I criticized him harshly, then
yes, I did do that. Okay. So anyway, anyway, heat means having
anger for someone, which you clearly do, I'm going to go ahead
and assume this heat you have for him is a product of liken straight
raid bad faith power couple in your ear since the last stream
where you were bought weren't bought 100% into the Ethan bad
narrative.
You had DG your brain examine your own agency. That's a watcher.
That's a watcher. Why do you have to try so hard to give DG the
worst name possible? Coming from very violent is very funny.
That's very funny.
Anyway, sorry. Did I grab this Pisco tweet? Where is it? Here.
Where is it? Where is it? This is it right here. There's more
Pisco aristocracy cuz I think I asked Aristocracy if she wanted
to come on tonight. We'll see if uh that does anything. Uh re
H3. So, this is the the heat tweet we saw before. Didn't you
just graduate law school? How much experience do you have in
California media law? I find it hilarious. Well, these are federal
laws, aren't they? Um, I find it hil It's literally a federal
complaint. There are federal complaints. California media law.
What the [__] are we talking about? That's That's
rough. Didn't you just graduate law school? How much experience
do you have in California media law doesn't know that it's a
federal lawsuit? It's kind of up. It's a little up. It's crazy.
Didn't you Okay. Uh, sorry. I find it hilarious that you're so
quick to dismiss the complaints as trash. By the way, Pisco is
going to annihilate her for this, I'm guessing. Okay. place is
trash when they're written by such a respected and successful
attorney. At least counter one of the arguments. No, I didn't
just graduate law school. I graduated law school in 2021. Your
use of the term California media law shows your ignorance. None
of these claims arise out of California state law, but federal
copyright law. The case Ethan leads with is out of the SDNY,
not California. And of course, it's applicable because we're
dealing with the federal copyright statute. The complaint is
trashy because it is long, is too long, uses unprofessional language,
includes a memorandum of law, unfair use, which is not appropriate
at the pleading stage, is replete with irrelevant and probably
strikable allegations, is formatted poorly, contains far too
many footnotes, and generally reads like. You can attack my bonafides
as much as you like, but the complaint is trashy as Yeah, Pisco
kind of won. It did. He thought looking at other initial complaints
or whatever that it seemed normal.
It depends on how far outside of the things complaint about footnotes.
Why would that be why would explaining themselves or giving more
context? He's saying he doesn't like the like he's saying that
professionally he doesn't like it, right? Professionally he thinks
you could write this more effectively. Like he literally criticized
the pros, right? He didn't say I he would never argue because
he's not a loser that this makes the legal arguments worse, right?
or that it like it makes their legal claim uh unjustified or
invalid, right? He would just say, "I don't like it. It's not
arguing." Well, I think I would want to look at his uh coverage
of it cuz unprofessional language. Is he just going to be like
a like so nitpicky? I think he's going to say that it takes away
from like Ethan like it he he doesn't understand. So, it's he
thinks it's like trying way too hard to be a PR piece when it
could be like an effective legal document because they probably
have a case, but it's like it's watered down the effective legal
arguments because because it's including things that have no
standing, no basis. Go ahead. Yeah. So, he's implying like, oh,
this writing is really bad. The lawyers must have been like what?
Neutered by Ethan. All of the bad stuff in here must be Ethan
controlling the lawyers. I don't I don't think that's his argument.
You're saying he would say it's more effect like Ethan making
this more of a PR piece than a than it being legal? Um well yeah
sure sure. So Ethan can give the direction for like what he wants
in there. Maybe that you know what maybe that is the argument.
I I was like no I don't think he's saying that. That's how I
interpret it. But I guess we would have to watch his coverage.
So, it would be yeah, Ethan telling his lawyers, "No, I want
that included." Or or that the lawyers are like I think the lawyers
will do what you ask, right? But I don't know. I've seen some
people in Pisco's community say that this lawyer is like harming
their own reputation with such a poorly written complaint, but
I I don't know. Yeah, I'm not I'm not a lawyer. I don't understand
why they would say that. Uh, aristocracy responded to herself
says, "Also, the complaints challenge your entire worldview,
so I'm not surprised you found them personally upsetting." What?
What's Pisco's entire worldview that got challenged?
What? Hold on. What does that even mean? I mean, isn't that projection
on her, too? I don't even I actually Yeah, sure. I just I don't
get it. Sorry. I really actually I don't get it at all.
Okay. I don't know if they I don't know if they go back and forth
at all anymore. Oh, hold on, though. Let's see. Not really sure
why you sidestep the question about the quality of the lawyer.
Would the conclusion from the quality of his writing be that
he is a bad lawyer or poorly representing his client? Why not
actually make the harder claims that actually target the poor
professional? I didn't say it was from a bad lawyer. didn't comment
on that at all. I said if it if I drafted the complaint, I would
be embarrassed. Find me saying the lawyer is bad. That's super
weasly legal talk right there, isn't it? Isn't it? I feel like
that's saying I didn't say he was a I don't think you're a bad
streamer. I just said if I streamed the way you do, I'd be embarrassed
of myself. But I didn't say you were a bad streamer. Like I'm
sorry. That's to me I don't know how you say that without without
implying their dog. Right. Sorry. Do you disagree, Cherry? I
think that's what you're saying, right? that the implication
is there that he's a bad lawyer. So, the thing that I disagree
on is um what am I disagreeing on? I just don't know if these
are valid complaints coming from Pisco. If this is just like,
oh, well, me personally, I don't like this many footnotes. I
think that you should be able Like, that just seems like a difference
in opinion on how you should go about writing something up. It
doesn't seem like there's actually anything wrong with having
a lot of footnotes. You're just being like a diva. Yeah, I I
think he would lean more towards that. I had to read this. I
had to read this on stream and it's so annoying having to go
from here and then look down and what's footnote number three.
Ah, too many footnotes.
Like, okay, buddy, but does it do the job? Is that kind of how
it's expected to happen in court? Yeah, I think so. I do know
one of his arguments is is that it's like watered down, as in
they have like solid arguments, but because they wanted to include
so many irrelevant things, it is like watered down, it makes
it a less persuasive argument. Um, probably not to the point
that it's like actually detrimental. It's just like not a good
like having to support these things. It gives the other side
like more things to to like point to saying like this is wrong,
this is wrong. I think I think that's probably like I guess you
could argue in terms of if you give the other side a whole bunch
of things to like object to, you're going to just kind of be
patting your pockets, right? Like it's poorly it's not efficient.
Maybe um
speak through it if you're not supposed to put everything you
possibly could in your complaint, right? Yeah. I think so. The
way I'd look at it is like it doesn't diminish your legal rights,
but ultimately like some of these things will have to go in front
of like a jury or you will have to make these arguments and the
arguments themselves are not going to be persuasive if they're
watered down with a bunch of things that don't matter, especially
like towards a jury, right? Yeah. But is it is it normal to not
include like the the smaller weaker points because then somebody
looking at the whole thing will be like, "Oh, look at these four
weak points. How pathetic they really take away from those three
really strong points in the beginning." I I imagine it's probably
normal to have smaller, weaker points that you just don't want
to leave out anything. Like I'm not actually sure how bad of
a decision that is or if it's just somebody trying to point to
something and try to make it sound like it's bad or weak. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not sure. I guess I do have his video up so we can
we can check that out in a little bit. But I think um we're probably
just about through this. We could get to some of the videos we
have. I think I want to start with denims. Yeah, I'm pretty sure
I want to start with Denims has like some comments out at this
point on things. Let's check it out because we didn't get a chance
to go through a lot of this stuff yesterday. So, we good. So,
Denim's actual response on Twitter. Oh man, you know what? I
actually lied. We're not going to that first cuz otherwise we're
going to lo context. So, now we are going to Pisco's legal reaction.
The purpose of this is not financial gain. People like XQC and
Asmin Gold may have watched the entire thing, but So, we've got
Pisco's
thing here. I think breaking down Ethan's new video. I think
we might want to skip to reading Ethan's complaint. Was Denim's
reaction transformative? Reading more of the complaints. I don't
think we need his like his breakdown of the video, right? I think
I think we can skip forward. Or do you do you want to watch it?
Uh it's it it's not like too big a deal either way. You decide.
I would never sue them just for doing that. I don't want to chill
the reaction community into fear. Whoa.
That's bad faith, too. Just be honest, Ethan. Man, I mean, this
is just You wouldn't want a chill XQC. XQC who you started the
video by saying you don't he doesn't give a about the cop. I
I hope that I know I have some other DJs around. Okay. I hope
that if they can hear it in Pisco's voice, maybe this is one
that they won't like just tie to Hassan and like dismiss immediately.
I think I hope I hope cuz like it's so clear to me that he is
trying to invoke the XQC thing to say I'm like standing on principle
here, but he's not really doing that at all. I law he doesn't
care if he's breaking the law. Why wouldn't you want to chill
that kind of thing? You're going after these people because you
don't like them and that's your right as copyright holder. To
me, it's a pretty open and shut infringement. I'm just saying
like the rationale behind who you're suing, who you're not suing,
that doesn't make any sense. Casey Tron is often too obliterated.
They should put scare quotes there or something. That is inappropriate.
This is a legal filing. And they put quote, "Indeed, Caseyron
is too obliterated to comment on the nuke." The alt left's answer
to Kelly Anne Conaway. Guys, save it for the stream. This is
formatted. So Dan Clansancy. Now we're talking about Dan Clansancy.
This is one of the worst complaints I've ever read in my life.
Hey folks, please like, comment, and subscribe. Okay, I don't
I actually don't care on the video. I want to skip to the Denim's
complaint cuz I think this is going to be the core part of this
will be the Denim's complaint. We can see his reaction to the
Grand Wy photos and those arguments. See what he has to say on
those and we can continue on. Legal mindset put up a fact video
about Ethan's case, too. He has no horse in this race, so it's
more neutral. Why do you think why do you think Pisco has a horse
in this race or that he's changing his opinion based on his horse
in the race? Okay. Well, given the topic of all of this controversy,
I'm going to say I do super care about the content of this video.
And even though we're just going to watch this portion, I would
probably recommend everybody go check out the video, check out
his YouTube channel, give it a like, and probably get the beginning
context of this. I'm sure it's very good and very valuable information
in there and not at all worthless. Did I say it was worthless?
I'm sorry if I said that. You guys should absolutely support
his content and his event.
We should uh Okay. I'm positive. Listen, guys. I'm not very good.
I'm a little autistic. I'm positive that was uh Cher's way of
saying we should actually watch the full video. So, I'm going
back and watch
they would reupload. You literally you listen to the intro and
you're like, "Yeah, I don't care about any of this, so I'm going
to go right to this part of the video." which is very dismissive,
very rude when you are reacting to someone else's content in
the midst of the ReactGate controversy lawsuit thing that's happening.
So, you're just I thank you for correcting me on that. I don't
think that it's pointless at all. I don't think it's any kind
of pointless at all. I think that what I meant was to to keep
this down and to be able to get through a lot of the other content
to be able to to get to the stuff I want to go over today and
and collect the arguments. I've seen some of the this stuff or
I've heard some of Pisco's arguments because I listened to his
space earlier today and so this will be duplicative for me, but
probably for everybody. I'm guessing it is quite good. I'm guessing
his his content would be quite good. So, disrespecting Pisco,
not something I'm a fan of. Thank you. But I just um we can go
back. We We can listen to it a little bit. I'm probably going
to what? Get through some of the ETH stuff. Trying to think of
where I want to go to. I might want to get to more of the Denim's
content in here. No, we'll go through it. If it slows down or
if I'm finding it slowing down, I'll uh I'll wait. Same thumbnail
or sorry. Please tell me you understand what I was saying though.
I do understand.
Okay. Cuz it's you do not have to watch it. You just do not have
to tell people that it's useless to watch. That's it. All right.
Okay. It's not useless to watch. It is not serving the exact
piece of content we want to do right now. That's what it is.
Saying that I'm targeting women that I'm a hypocrite for suing
for copyright infringement. just have this to say. Did he only
sue women? I don't care. What I do hope though is that you'll
support their crowdfunding efforts to defend themselves because
let's face it, I want to make sure there's money left over for
me when I win my lawsuits. You don't care about whether you're
a hypocrite. So, this is what he starts with, right? Very clear
visual here. Should he see every single person who reacted to
his content and lose 90% of the cases just to be principled?
No. I I can't imagine Pis going stuff. Which do you think XC
Moore falls in? Why so dismissive of Cherry? In what way was
I dismissive there? I literally said she was right. And thank
you for pointing out that like I kind of dismissed Pisco's content.
That is very helpful to me cuz if Pisco watched that and only
saw that clip or if somebody linked it to him, obviously he he
that could like hurt his feelings. That could lead to like him
not wanting to come on stream or something. It would be like
total, right? Yeah. I wouldn't dismiss him at all. In the camp
of the top or the bottom of my Bro, I want to support you, but
these forced attempts at nuance are too painful. Bro, what are
you talking about? I'm giving you my real take if you don't like
it because you just want me to what? So many people are like
this. It's actually so annoying.
Hey, this would be a permanent ban for me if you leave a comment
like this. Oh, actually um well, I was going to I kind of liked
you, but I'm going to check back in a couple months cuz like
this is really annoying. Uh yeah, banned. Walk the away silently
or or you will be gone. Okay, I will leave silently or I will
shoot you in the head in a video game in the chat. Okay. Thank
you. Regurgitate your opinion at you. That That's what you want
me to do. Regurgitate for you what you believe. I will have you
know and not actually challenge you and give you my actual take.
I won't have I won't let you know anything cuz he's just going
to have the video keep playing.
I clicked off of this window and didn't refocus it instantly.
Sorry. Cherry did not treat
any unique way last time. That was Pisco. Pisco is a in debates.
Pisco is annoying in debates. He knows he is. That's why he should
not get offended when somebody yells at him and calls him a He
knows how he is. If that stops him from coming on this stream,
whatever. He should hide in a closet for the rest of his life.
It wouldn't stop him from coming on this stream. I think uh problem
if Pisco were to stop coming on this stream or if he didn't want
to talk to me, that would have entirely to do with my relationship
with Pisco and not anybody else at all. I don't I didn't even
see what Felp said, but if there was like an implication that
you were like mean to him or something, that has nothing to do.
Wait, why do you not say that? Why am I starting to talk and
you don't even notice the chatter? How about just look at the
chat real quick and see what sparked it so you can actually be
informed and as to why you're responding to this. Okay. Uh, he
probably would come on stream anyways because of the way Cherry
treated him last time. Just remember that a lot of people who
watch the stream are on audio only, so they do actually need
to hear that read out. Stop saying why is she so mean today.
I literally have the most reasonable request when I do speak
up. I'm just very assertive about it and your little panties
are in a bunch because of it. Does not make me so mean. It just
makes me so direct. Are you so uncomfortable?
No. Spectre. Thank you for the gifted sub.
And guys, don't forget if you like the content, if you want the
content to go longer, more time on the stream, you can sub yourself.
You can sub individually on kick. You can gift subs on kick.
You can sub on Twitch. You can throw me a Twitch primer if you're
over on Twitch. Okay, there's so many ways for you to sub, for
you to gift money for to make the stream go longer. I appreciate
every piece of monetization you guys help with. Okay, sick monkey
chamber. Thank you for the 10 months. Was that over on Kick or
Twitch? That was over on kick. Oh, there's a celebration as well.
Thank you. Thank you. Uh, what else is there? Oh, yes. Also,
TTS exclamation point donate in the chat. We have fixed the donation
links. So, if you guys want to donate through Kickbot, okay,
all the AI TTS voices, they work perfectly. Exclamation point
donate in the chat. We'll give you the links. $2 minimum on TTS
on Kickbot, $3 minimum on Streamlabs. Get your TTS read on stream.
Get your questions answered just in case we ignore you in chat
like I did to Felp earlier. Thankfully, Cherry was there to point
out that he's a
Sorry, fell pal. It wasn't the fact that you ignored him is you
were going to respond to what you think he might have said in
which you should just like scroll up and read what he said so
your response can just be accurate. Damn.
When the scroll button is right there, it's true. If you guys
keep trying to pretend that Cherry's like going insane or something,
she will eventually just leave. You can you can actually annoy
people. I'm going insane. Where did you see that iteration? What's
what's changed? How come Cherry's like this? Did she did he lose
a bet or something? Cuz people are like trying to So where did
you see insane?
Uh so where did you see insane turn of phrase? Whose turn of
phrase did did he lose a bet? The turn of phrase is insane. Uh
it's implying you're not acting rationally or not acting like
in a way you normally would. If you lost a bet, I'm irrational.
Or are you like reaching? Okay. And what? Giving your chatters
maybe something to cling on to now. You setting a new narrative.
Are you having fun? We're all having fun. Everything I'm saying
is fair and valid. This must really suck for you. Uh-huh. Okay.
But I think if you imply like your chat's calling me insane,
maybe that'll help you help you out a bit, right? Nope. The bottom.
All right. And let's see what what does Ethan call the bottom
type of video. Actually, now understandably this made a lot of
people angry because why should these content thieves essentially
get more views than the author of the video which in a lot of
So he's adopting this position. He's calling them content thieves,
people who do the the bottom. He's saying this makes people mad,
right? These is content thieves. He's calling this this situation
thievery. the people who do the bottom and we've just acknowledged
that XC fits the bottom lot of cases was happening. I mean, people
don't like injustice and this just we all see this. This was
yesterday, man. It's like Pisco watched some really smart people
discuss these topics or something. What a guy. He calls it injustice.
He says people who do the bottom what we just showed you where
we know. So, when you put together two things, I would say if
it's injustice and you are a moral actor and trying to paint
yourself as a moral actor, which he is in both of these cases,
in both the documents and his video, he is trying to paint himself
as somebody who's protecting, right? He is a protector. He is
helping the space. He's protecting the space. If you try to paint
yourself that way, then it is incumbent, it is incumbent on you
to go after XQC
because he is the far larger creator creating a far larger problem
and he is far more egregious than Denims. But you're going, "No,
no, but Denims hurt my feelings. XQC, he's okay. He didn't hurt
my feelings."
Why? Aren't you Aren't you the guy protecting the space? No,
that's what XQC does. He called it quote an injustice. All right.
This debate culminated when XQC one of the prime suspects called
in to my show. He calls XQC one of the prime suspects. That is
to say, because we all know it, he does that. He is a purveyor
of that injustice. One of the prime suspects of people doing
this kind of is XQC.
All right? And I'm following Ethan this entire time. You scroll
back to this video. I say, "Yeah, Ethan has this history, this
pattern. He's he's based. I believe him when he says this stuff,
and I've seen him debate XQC on it." So up to now I think Ethan
Klein is completely base and correct and I I think that this
is true to debate me in which case I'm sad to report that I was
uh terribly owned. So in that regard do you care at all about
like IP or copyright? Do you care at all about IP or copyright
or like the fact that it's illegal? Does that matter if that
it might be illegal? Uh does that matter to you? Uh no it doesn't
matter. Uh no. Well, if if flat out doesn't because it flat out
doesn't matter to me what the law says. Rereaming done through
Discord streams that don't make money. Seems hard to enforce.
Also, nobody called JSDLK a pause any ever again. Isn't the Hassan
rereaming done through Discord streams? No, that's not what happens.
No, it's done through DG chat through somebody like explicitly
going and rereaming him. Yeah. Yep. That's I'm stealing or not.
Thanks for the five. Hold screen cam. Do the [__]
war and watch your watch content for a week. Do a week of no
reaction content and see how many [__] views you
get. And this is him, Ethan, because it is his belief that this
guy is a thief and and this whole reaction comes out of this
debate. I got to go crack. Bye. I mean, that's content, man.
At least the ultimate debate. Cherry might be back in a little
bit, I think. Bro, he hit him with the worm and he's criticizing
XQC and I'm with Ethan this entire time watching the video. Yeah,
based I think of that first. I kid XQC, but he is not the one
I'm suing despite my So he's like, "All right, he disagrees with
him, but I'm not suing him. Criticism, he's not a malicious infringer,
but the ones he's not a malicious infringer.
So he's pervy injustice. He's a prime suspect, but he's not malicious.
I'm sorry. What? Absolute
dog water. No one believes that whatso if that is not malicious,
I don't know what is. I don't care if I'm stealing or not. IP
the law. And you've heard him say much worse than that. He's
not a malicious infringer.
Dude, didn't he say, "Uh, yeah, I am." I I thought his like position
at some point was like, "Yeah, I am breaking the law. Sue me
if you wanted to change." You not entirely what he said? Hey,
I am breaking the law. You sue me if I'm breaking the law. I
could have sworn he was. Well, then everything you said about
injustice here, no one can believe you. You called this an injustice.
Hang on. You called this an injustice.
You said it was an injustice. He pvveys the injustice. He doesn't
care that he's doing it. And that's not malicious. He's not a
malicious infringer. Yeah, these are his dude. He watched some
really smart people go over this stuff. Like really, really,
really intelligent people. XC lets you take the income from his
reacts too. benefits this that benefits a lot of people. No,
not everybody has their stuff set up through content ID. But
hold on. You understand that you can't take that unless you have
special setups, right? That when you content ID something, you
can make them take it down. You can't make them give you your
your ad revenue through the standard content ID. That is not
how that works. You have to have it registered with YouTube in
a special way to be able to just snipe their revenue. And basically,
nobody has that. XQC is not a moral actor. This is not cool.
That is complete.
And then where does he do it? Let's see. People like Hassan reacting
to entire TV shows on stream. My fear is that Sony or Disney
comes along, sues everybody, and sets a devastating precedent
that could endanger our entire field. Now,
where is that going to happen, guys? Where is that most likely
to happen? Is that going to be them suing Caseyron or is that
going to be some big company like them suing someone like XQC,
somebody with scale, somebody who is doing lazy reacts at scale
so that they will go after them, right? Like it's obvious that
XQC is the primary concern or somebody like XQC or Asmin Gold.
Asold I think gets closer to the line where Ethan says he doesn't
want to go. I don't even know if you can protect that line to
be honest with you. It's his fear. His fear is that Disney and
Sony come in and do a lawsuit that with all of their rights.
That's what he wants you to believe.
So you tell me that's honestly without this I feel like so much
better, right? I feel so much better without this part. Like
this is just him trying to say like and if you're criticizing
me, well here's why you shouldn't. Cuz I'm trying to help everybody
guys. I'm trying to help all of us. No, you're not. Stop. What
is uh what is it? What did they say in uh Never mind. It's just
it's double speak. It's really annoying. What is more likely
to trigger a lawsuit from Sony or Disney?
The kind of
Zan Kelly, you are timed out for an hour for not engaging with
the argument. That wasn't the argument I made. I didn't say you
have to sue everybody else. I said if you want to pretend you're
a moral actor, you should sue the people who are actually causing.
Okay? The people who are actually causing the harm that you say
you want to prevent that you explicitly just said in your video
you're seeking to prevent. If you want to help there, you should
sue the person who's doing more harm. That is unequivocally obviously
true. How about you open your ears, clean out your brain, okay?
Just give I need you to think really hard. Okay, you just said,
"Oh, well, how could you possibly sue Casey Tron when XQC is
there?" That's not the That's not the argument. That's not You're
literally talking to nobody. Come back in a little bit. Bye-bye.
That XQC does or the kind of that Froggen at all just do. You
tell me. XQC is bigger. XQC reacts to more mainstream stuff.
That alone, so if you were actually far less substantive reacts
concerned with the state of the reaction community and fear of
chilling lawsuits from these big bad guys, we would be trying
to police our own the worst offenders.
And the worst offenders absolutely includes XQC and friends owned.
Oh, by the way, if anybody wants to call in, line up in the waiting
room, okay? Waiting room now. You want to hop in? Waiting room
now. Waiting room now. Waiting room now.
Anyway, all of you guys destroyed, demolished. That said, these
people are like very clearly infringers. Take a look at the lawsuit
real quick. I don't have a problem with him suing them at all.
Oh, they actually included The Nightmare on Denim Street. This
is I sure hope that Pisco knows when he goes to review this that
that is not from Denim's reaction to the content nuke. Okay,
it is not. Oh my god, it's funny, but it's cringe. This lawsuit
is about ending the practice of lazy reaction videos. Uh Stazzy,
you just haven't been watching the stream, dude. Okay, so complete
vindication for me. That's not what this lawsuit's about. That's
not what this lawsuit's about. So I'm completely vindicated.
He is pretending to be a savior.
He has a savior complex. It's the first sentence. So, everyone
can absolutely
give me props for being completely right. If that's what this
lawsuit was about, you wouldn't throw You would say, "I'm not
suing XQC because the cases are better against them, but XC is
part of the problem." Right? You don't even have to sue XQC.
I'm not even saying sue XC. I'm saying you have to identify XQC
as part of the problem. You can't say XQC is not part of the
problem. You have to say XC is part of the problem. I think Ethan
would say XQC is a part of the problem. I don't think you have
to sue him. I just think you have to give up your rationale that
you're trying to protect people. Right. Right. Lawsuit is about
ending the practice of lazy reaction videos that copy entire
copyrighted works and purposely siphon views and revenue away
from the original that copy entire purposely yes lazy reaction
videos. So from from step one that is not what Denims did. It's
just not like it's is just lying
right. This lawsuit is about ending the practice of lazy reaction
videos purposely siphoned. Hold on.
Where is it not purposeful? Where is it not purposeful when XUC
watches an entire video and reuploads it in its entirety to YouTube
with the same thumbnail? Where is that not purposeful? It's certainly
not it's not delineated in any way within law. There is zero
delineation there. Unless you're arguing that Ethan wants to
actually create new legal uh like he wants to write law somehow
from this. How is he going to write law?
seven years ago, the owners of plaintiff Ted Entertainment
established a legal standard for fair use reaction videos in
hos and dies. Yeah, we really appreciate that. Ted Entertainment
as a genre reaction videos very widely. Bro, where are the pins
sites? Where are the pins sites? You don't pin site the quote.
Uh-oh.
That's going to trigger me. Reaction videos like quote like the
client video that interpose short segments. Emphasis added constitute
fair use. Wait a second. Where's the pin sites? So the citations,
they're not blue booking. Do they at italicize this period? I
can't tell. If not, okay, so that answers Cherry's question on
whether Pisco is just being like super pedantic about like nothing
that doesn't really affect the legal arguments at all. Is this
really not it atalicized? Is this really not formatted correctly?
Points deducted. The problem here with with having this is you
don't know what's emphasis added, what's not, right? Is emphasis
added just for this? Is emphasis added just for that? So really,
really shitty citations in terms of the format of the citations.
In my opinion, this case involves a uh trap house. Yes, we should
mock and denigrate Denims and Casey Tron and Frogan for for doing
this. It's obviously disgusting. I think the legal part is just
stupid. A group viewing session hosted by defendants. I agree
with that. The moderators heavily promoted this. Yes, true. Badly
formatted footnote. They profited like most lazy reaction videos
peppers her per group with primarily brief and sporadic observations.
They'll watch long un adulterated portions of the works to give
surface level. That's a good citation. I like this. Other times,
Denim's commentary has little to no critical bearing on the cell
or substance of the works. Wait, the works include what? Actually,
the works include the content nuke and then the show episode.
Got it. On the rare occasion when Denims does provide sporadic
or brief commentary, she spread, "Oh, Ozel just got timed out
for an hour in the Discord for calling out all of the people
who were complaining in Gen Chat to me, saying I was wrong and
now they don't want to hop on the stream." Ozel called them out
and then he was destroyed. He was smited for that. Okay, I agree
with you, Ozel. I agree with you. Okay, I won't undo that timeout
because I don't give a um but you're totally correct. You did
you did something righteous. Okay. And I will remember it misinformation
that is refuted. Okay. That's not relevant. But I guess part
of the story on the rare occasions when she actually shows the
factual basis for her claim or statements are refuted by the
cited source itself. Such misinformation fails to serve copyright's
goal of enriching public knowledge. Wait, hold on. Huh? Actually,
J. If it is fair use, your criticism of denims is the same as
your criticism for H3. Just because you are within your legal
rights to do this doesn't mean you aren't a for doing it. What?
Can you say it again? I don't even know what you're talking about
there. a second. You'd have to explain what you mean here. Oh,
right, right, right, right, right. Yeah, sure. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
Sorry. Yes, but come on. It is the same thing. I was not understand.
This lawsuit is to hold Denims accountable. Wait, wait, wait.
Basis for a claim or statements are refuted by the cited source
itself. Such misinformation fails to serve copyright goals. So
Pisco reads this and I don't know if he got the whole thing,
but it's basically arguing that the reason Denim's reaction is
bad, right? That it's a group viewing session is because her
observations are
that's the legal argument right here. Actually, her her arguments
are dumb. So it's not actually it's not transformative at all.
It's just a group watching party because her her arguments are
dumb. When she pauses and says something is dumb. Love enriching
public evil knowledge chatter thing for the 19 months. Come on.
Empty chairs at empty tables. This lawsuit is to hold denims
accountable and the H3 snark mods accountable. Are they parties?
Oh, they are parties. Yo, actually sued the Reddit mods.
Insane.
Hilarious. She's He's suing the the Reddit mods. Good. We need
to sue more Reddit mods. The alt left's answer to Wait, Lake
Toyo, we uh we heard your comment. Your comment came through.
you in. We should set up something for what we disagree on or
some on sometime like Zog versus relig or religion or blacks.
Okay, maybe Max maybe at some point. Maybe Conway guys. I don't
Jesus Christ. Not in your complaint. Save it for the stream.
So unprofessional. This is formatted. So again, these are nitpicks.
You guys can get mad. This is my reaction.
Shocking. The Yeah, exactly. Second, I don't by the way. I don't
think it'll pass fair use, but I think I think the bar by which
we judge most content creators, most streamers for fair use,
she passes that bar. She doesn't pass the legal bar. She passes
the bar we all understand to be like where we're playing at,
right? She's like, she's totally in on what the group understanding
is, right? She totally is. Alt left's answer to Kellyanne Conaway.
Denims. This is also false. No one knows who this person is outside
of the online sphere. Denim's lars as a Hey Max, thank you very
much for the five gifted. Let's thank you. Thank you. Evolutionary
from the Okay, now I'm starting to This is an unhinged filing.
It It probably will. On leftovers episode 53, Ethan is watching
XQCD React content and he says he's literally just sitting there
quietly for the first 30 seconds. You should sue him. You guys
you xQc you thief. I'm not surprised he's stealing videos. Oh,
interesting. Yeah, that's not shocking that he's done that. Pass
a motion to dismiss because it's almost certainly infringement,
but it's unhinged. It's actually more professional than some
of the president than the president EOS. It's actually more professional
than our president's filings as well. How did a serious lawyer
write this? Because they wanted to beam, I guess. No, I I think
this Lykan I I think that this will go someplace. I don't think
this is a dead case at all. I think that this is a very good
case of infringement. you don't need to do this, but it's because
part of this is PR and part of this is uh legal filing, but I
don't think that this kind of maybe you can motion to strike
it because it's so like unneeded, but even then lawyers are given
quite a bit of leeway in terms of how they want to characterize
things. And so, I think it's very unprofessional. You know, maybe
it's effective in this day and age to like type like an unhinged
person. She's a prolific purveyor of misinformation and speaks
with great confidence. So, it is basically Pisco is saying he
doesn't believe that it is substantively bad. Like there is not
a he doesn't have a substantial reason. He just thinks it looks
bad. It looks unprofessional.
It just doesn't meet meet his personal code of conduct. That's
the only topic which where her knowledge leaves much to be desired.
This feels like Ethan wrote that line. Denims repeatedly inserts
herself into public controversies by employing poor judgment,
knee-jerk contrarianism, and a con consistent impulse to defend
the indefensible, including copyright infringement, terrorism,
and extreme. This is so cringe.
Stick to the case, guys.
This is so cringe. Denims is one of the most loyal and ardent
defenders of Hassan, the most prominent alt left streamer on
Twitch. Much like Scientologists engage in fair game. You cited
Wikipedia
for fair game definition.
Why do you need to do this
simile? This is shocking. Denims ruthlessly attacks with reckless
abandon anyone who disagrees with her or her son. She parrots
Hassan's style, rhetoric, and content strategy. No, we've not
seen the Destiny reaction to this. We've not seen that. Um I
although, now that I'm thinking about it, hold on. Do we want
to look at it? I might I might actually look at it because if
we're going to watch the Pisco, if he if he reacts to this exact
part, if I can find him going through like Pisco's comments here,
cuz I would love to see what the commentary is. Very interesting.
This is so maybe none of this is factually relevant. As such,
he has assumed a leading role in Hassan's quote waiting room.
A collective of streamers who cultishly follow Hassan and parasitically
leech off of his audience by streaming before and after him.
Denims read Osama bin Laden's letter to America. She frequently
express what does that have to do with infringement of your content
nuke video? Like it it's not just that it doesn't have to do
with it. It's not even like arguably related, right? It's not
even a little bit argue. It's not like um it's not like it could
speak to intent in some way. It's not like it's not arguably
related in any way. It's not speaking to any kind of patterns.
It's just saying this person sucks.
She sucks. All of this should be stricken. This is getting to
the point I think of being like I don't know if it's sanctionable.
Probably not. But insane. Balenciaga BDSM.
This is so
bad. She committed copyright infringement. Oh, that's what I
said when I read. I was like, "Wait, is he arguing that she did
copyright infringement on Osama bin Laden of a filing?"
Imagine you're reading this and you have no idea who the these
people are. You're just like like, "Isn't this an infringement
case? This is such a filing so far. Her prior beliefs, her beliefs
about infringement,
they're not an issue in the case. I just don't know what what
it matters. My my chat is triggered. Would adding the relevant
commentary upset a judge? I think it might. Yeah. Imagine you're
a judge, like an old boomer 80-year-old judge trying to follow
this. It's just a mess. Just stick to the video. There is this
video Ethan. I registered the video on this day. This has happened
on this day. This happened. This is what the video does. This is
what the reaction is. The reaction was done on the same day.
Like why are we starting with like the Kellyanne Cono? It's just
it would me off reading if I'm a judge now. I know some of these
people, but like imagine you don't know who Shuan Head is. You
don't know what Balenciaga is. I think Pisco's argument here
is something along the lines of like you're an old judge and
let's say you think it's critical to know who Shuan Head is to
understand the arguments, right? And so you spend time googling
Shuan head. You take like 20 minutes out of your day, 30 minutes
out of your day that you're not getting back. You look it all
up and then once you understand, you see, oh, this is actually
totally unrelated. I don't think there's any relevance to the
case whatsoever. Right? I you're then you're annoying the judge.
But Pisco is mostly making style arguments. I don't think Pisco
is arguing that like there will be an effect. It's just like
you're annoying the judge. If the the only reason you wouldn't
want to avoid annoy the judge is if you come down to like a 50/50
coin flip kind of decision later, you sure would love that judge
to like you, right? You sure would love for them to be like a
fan in some way to to think you make good arguments. That probably
what it goes to and that's probably where he's speaking from
is like you don't want to annoy the you don't want to be on people's
bad side. You want to be on their good side so that when it does
come down to an actual like judgment call and they get to have
some leeway to make their own decision, they consider you favorably.
You don't know why Errol Chiron matters through this infringement
case. you don't know what the Osama bin like it's just very tough
to follow if you're not terminally online and also I have to
say in my opinion irrelevant it's irrelevant it's relevant in
terms of the public discussion on it for sure but to the specific
case of infringement I just like don't understand what the relevance
is okay so previously she has said that she doesn't give a [__]
about infringement got it why is that relevant right like does
the fact that she doesn't give a [__] about infringement
have any tendency to prove one of the necessary elements in this
case no question about whether this video exists isn't at issue
it's undisputed she made a reaction video, it will be undisputed.
So, her tendency to infringe is not relevant. It's also bad and
and I don't think it's effective as a piece of um of legal right
and I don't think it's effective rhetorically. I'm going to give
my honest Yes, Lyan is commenting on Pisco's live stream. I believe
they get to it here with uh was Denim's reaction transformative?
Background of H3 Snark. H3 Snark is a part of a genre of message
boards known as subreddits on the website Reddit. Like just imagine
you're an eight. Imagine the judge assigned this as some 80-year-old
Reagan appointee. Oh, he's uh he's not going to get very far
through this, which is unfortunate because I do want to see his
reaction to once H3 Snark is like introduced. I would love to
see him have the same concern I did, which is like how is that
connected to Denims, right? And I'd love to see his opinion on
that. There's a snark message board of a subreddit on a Reddit
and you just little like you just got linked and you were supposed
to really watch all like
it's such a mess. H3 Snark was created by a fanatical Trisha
Pis fan. Trisha Pis
do number one became a fallen fan. Could you just Ier friendnemy?
Like I'm already speeding it up a little bit. I just imagine
a booer trying to get through this. Yes, the friend show like
does no idea who Date is. No idea what Frenemies is. It's hilarious.
I mean like I'm enjoying it. I'm not saying it's a mess and disaster
of a filing on a very strong case. I'm not even 40. I don't understand
it. H3 Snark has become a haven for fallen fans. Amazing. It's
a haven for fallen fans. the average viewer would move on with
their lives after this is Trump. This is literally maybe this
is what the left needs to do to become more effective is to turn
into Trump. This is how Trump talks. H3 Stark enables the deranged
and I think we made that exact comment while we're reading this
that it's like it's very Trumpian the way they're like arguing
these things fallen fans to share their perverse pleasure of
hate watching TEI content with others by providing infringing
clips and links to TEI content. This is a complaint filed in
the current year. Insane filing, unhanded filing on a very strong
case. An insane filing. Ethan Hassan debated Taiwan such as whether
like I I have to I know I've been saying it like 10 times. I
just really want to stress again. Imagine you're a 70-year-old
like complex litigation judge who's been assigned this copyright
case. And then you start by you start by denims is the Kellyanne
Conway of the alt left shoe on head fallen fan haven uh genre
message board. H3 snark haven for fallen fans. They debated Tibet
Taiwan Ethan push back on proChina positions ecclesiastical parasocial.
I'm glad that Pisco is is following up like he he basically has
the opinion here that I assumed you would have is okay. While
this is annoying, it could annoy a judge. If you have a strong
case, it's not going to with you at all. Like it's just unfortunately
you're just you're kind of like wasting his time. He might be
he might say don't do it again, but it's not going to like weaken
the case. It's not going to make you like get dismissed or something.
And no judge is ever going to dismiss like a an actual case with
merit to it because you filed a like paperwork. What is happening?
You're citing Wikipedia for the term fair game scientology simile
that you don't need to do. You're talking about Balenciaga. You're
talking about things that are so irrelevant to the case. You're
dual Israeli American citizens. Eel was born in Israel where
she served as an ID. Who gives a for the infringement case whether
you serve in the IDF? While both Ethan and Eel are supportive
of Palestinian self-determination and extremely critical of Israel
and its government, the this literally reads like state propaganda.
I'm just being honest. In the wake of October 7th, Hassan emerges
the modern incarnation of the Grand Muti Hash Amin Al-Husini.
Wild. Absolutely wild. And I think it's the Grand Complete violent.
I would be embarrassed. Um, I'm not bringing Kelly on for the
exact reason I said before. Um, Kelly probably hasn't watched
any of these videos. She's probably not been keeping up with
this. I don't want to have that whole like detraction while I'm
like covering all of this. I love having Kelly on a whole bunch
of the time, but right now I don't think she's like caught up
on any of this and I'm just trying to I'm trying to I have a
whole bunch of things I want to cover. Okay. Whole bunch of things
I want to cover with people who I feel like will have looked
into it. Defile anything. I've been here for the last two and
a half hours. Yeah, I know you've been watching today, but I'm
saying overall it's just like not really that interesting. I
know you want to come on stream, but I'm I'm good right now.
Even 5% this unhinged citing a video about the Grand Muy on the
world history. This would this would put me the [__]
off. Too many footnotes, guys. Way too many footnotes. This is
a complaint. What are you doing? Look at the footnotes.
This is insanity. Like like Al Husseini, Hassan has become a
passionate advocate and highly charismatic leader of the Palestinian
cause. citing Benny Morris for the for the claim that Hassan
had become passionate or for the claim like Al Husseini was a
passionate advocate. You don't need to cite a historian for all
of these points. Have you watched Denim's reaction yet? If not,
why are you assuming it's infringement? Why am I assuming it's
infringement? Like, are you serious? Because she copied the video.
She performed the video and I know Denims. Have you watched Denim's
reaction yet? If not, why are you assuming it's infringement?
Oh man, I feel like if Lyan was just arguing, why are you arguing?
If you're saying why are you arguing it's not transformative
or that like cuz I think that's a a key distinction. Um I think
it's probably infringement in that all of these things are infringed.
Are you arguing it's going to be fair use protected? No way.
Not a shot. So I'll ask that specifically if you liken which
of the fair use factors cuts in denim saver. Which of the four
fair use factors cuts in denim saver? Actually I'll bring up
let's bring up the fair use factors and then you can identify
which of them. I do think it's transformative. I think it's transformative.
Cuts it her way in terms of being transformative. That's what
Mike will say. You know this is in many ways it's a dramatic
work. There's something. Oh, I would say um the purpose and character
of it. Um Oh, no, no, no. Not that. It's that it is meant to
be like educational or a critique,
This would go to the first one, but then the first one I think
you lose because it is literally trying to be commercially like
a commercial alternative factual component to it. And so at best
it's neutral, but I think it cuts one. No, no. Uh oh, sorry.
Two. No, sorry. Two is what I think. two I think cuts in her
favor and one cuts in her favor against denims if I'm being honest.
It's literally intended to be and is served as a potential market
substitute. So that cuts against denims. The purpose and character
of the use is it transformative? No, it's spares commentary.
So please, which of these factors cuts in dem's favor? Spar's
commentary. You lose me because that's not actually true. Okay.
On that I I will admit I will admit having not seen the denim's
reaction video. I'm relying on Ethan's characterizations to say
it's fair. Okay. Oh, that's actually Damn, this guy's good. This
guy's good at arguing. He just knows. He knows immediately that
oh, I actually am only relying on one side for that. Never mind.
I will admit that. And I could be wrong about that. So I could
be wrong on fair use for that specific actor if in fact it wasn't
Spar's commentary. But given the fact that she's leaving at times
and maybe I'm conflating the reaction video versus the um sorry
the prepared video versus the stream, then you're just moving
to the copyright copyrighted works is whatever you know. So that
would be factor one. But every other factor cut against her heavily
in my opinion. Separately I'll try to find the venom's reaction
video since you're going to call me on it and I'll I'll try to
see if I consider it to be sparse. But here's the thing, right?
If there Why is he saying it like that? Spares. It's sparse.
say sparse pill in which she's like five 10 minute stretches
where she's not commenting on it or where it's not transformative
at all. I think that factor is going to cut against her. So if
you can because again the amount of the work some of these factors
kind of intertwine if there's like a lot of heavy commentary
just but like just kind of spaced out and you don't need to use
as much of the work that you're using to achieve the kind of
critical do in other words you need to account if you're not
commenting fairly consistently then there's no reason to believe
you need the whole work. You could cut the amount of work you
need down and you're not doing any work towards that which will
speak against you. Yeah, sure. for the use of your video, right?
You could have some highly transformative edits of like Star
Wars, right? Let's say for the first 10 minutes it's highly,
you know, transformative Star Wars content fair use for the first
10 minutes, but the rest of it is playing Star Wars the movie
with like, oh, that's cool. Look at that. Then I think that it's
uh Oh, that's interesting. Second, that's interesting. The fact
that part of it is transformative. It's all related to like the
sub and substance of what you're using. So, I'll I'll make sure
to watch the D's reaction video and we'll see how I think the
nature of the copyrighted work in that it is a criticism. It
is like a political criticism. I feel like two actually cuts
against you a little bit. It's not that you can't copyright it.
It's that like, oh man, there has to be something there. We'll
see. I'll see if I can find something around this later. Completely.
Basically, like some sort of version of like implied license
for certain kinds of people, like the people you're in a an actual
public discourse with. This is one of the craziest complaints
I've seen in a while and just as crazy as some of the Trump complaints
for sure. These footnotes are skitso. You put a picture of Hitler
and Himmler. Why? So unprofessional. Absolutely unhinged. Trump
has never done anything this crazy. In terms of the atmospheric,
in terms of legal arguments, sure, Trump has done crazier things
in his violence. But in terms of That's funny. That's very funny.
I've never seen anything like this. Quoting Al Husseini, Arabs,
rise as one man and fight for your sacred rights wherever you
find them. This please God history and religion to save your
honor. God is with you on Nazi radio. So he's literally comparing
Hassan to like a Nazi a Nazi Hassan's not a party to the complaint,
by the way. The um collaborator. Why are you doing this? If some
boomer judge gets this, he's going to be like, "This is some
psycho manifesto. It's not good lawyering. It's not good advocacy.
I don't even think it's good PR. I don't think it even looks
good PR-wise. You have a strong case. Stick to the law. Stick
to the facts. And you don't need to include this. Embed this
in the complaint. Attach it as a Oh, look at how many exhibits
you have. Holy [__] You don't need to post this.
We get it. Just make it an attachment. Make it an exhibit. 80
pages. 80 pages.
Why? You don't need this to be 80 pages. This should be 20 pages
max. 80 pages. I'll give you 25. DNC takedown notices. Okay.
So, there's history. Okay, you don't need to do this. How this
doesn't trigger a bar complaint is going to be memes
entire thing here. Hark mods made concern effort to issue fraud
counter notifications. So, is this a is this a DMCA case? My
eyes are glazing over. Look at Look at these. Look at the It's
just raw URLs of Reddit threads and YouTube links. You up the
sizing here on footnote 33. This is a size down from the other.
That's a It's just funny that this is really really frustrating
for him that like the sizing is off. Uh we'll check that out.
Dice go. We'll check out the uh here the text isn't aligned.
The space
you went to the copyright office conference with the United States
copyright office. Okay. The nuke is a tragic comic documentary
critiquing Hassan and Twitch. It contains of original footage.
It contains of original footage. You guys proofread this at least
put it through [__] TAG GPT. The nuke can be this
is too many sections. And so now he's actually he's using this
to monologue. So he's monologuing about his concerns. You're
like describing the work. You can just make that a paragraph.
You don't need to give us a playbyplay. You're citing the UN
report. Dan Clansancy. Now we're talking about Dan Clansancy.
Damn. Okay. Somebody uh somebody dropped the URL for that in
my chat if you can. Okay. This is one of the worst complaints
I've ever read in my life. I looked at the White House YouTube.
I can't find it. Including the Loves Sabra. This is so indulgent.
We're at now 30. Okay. I'm I'll be two seconds here. Okay. I'll
be two seconds. D, now we're talking about Dan Clansancy. This
is one of the worst complaints I've ever read in my life. Froggen
loves. You're including the loves Sabra. This is so indulgent.
We're at now 35 footnotes on your complaint. Stephen made an
appearance. Very cool. Hassan, I don't know if Hassan referring
to you realizes inbred or laughing at you being inbred. So all
of that, that was like five pages of describing the video and
like [__] on Hassan and basically like re recapitulating
the video. But can I ask why? No guys. No guys. Guys, you don't
need to have this is not a memorandum of law. So now they're
doing legal analysis in their complaint. That's inappropriate.
Save that for the motion practice. You know, give give a paragraph
maybe to fair if you if you feel you have to, but save that for
the motion practice. Okay, it seems like a strong case. This
complaint is shocking, beyond the pale. The complaint is so unhinged.
It's unreadable. It's way too long. It's unprofessional, inappropriate,
wild case. But this complaint is a bad piece of legal advocacy.
It's a bad p piece of PR advocacy in my opinion. How much will
the complaint actually affect the chance of winning the case?
I don't think I don't know. I don't think it will affect I think
they'll maybe they'll have a motion to strike though because
some of this stuff here is it is completely inappropriate. Needs
more memes. Big picture, I think it's a strong case of infringement.
I don't think it's a strong case of fair use. I think there's
a neutral reason to target these people conceivably and not other
people. I think that the case is winnable for sure. I don't think
it matters that they set a trap. I don't think it matters that
there are other big fish that, you know, they're not suing. So
all that's big picture, but take take a step back and even bigger
picture. The notion that and this is not even disputable at this
point that H3 is acting like a savior for the fair use community,
the reaction community is so preposterous as to be insulting
to my and I believe it actually is a bit of disingenuousness
to start off with this broader concern about the quote injustice
regarding these kinds of streams that basically steal content
and don't transform the nature of the content at all or provide
any commentary to start with that view to show XQCB one of the
prime suspects, one of the biggest purveyors and then to try
to distinguish and say this is really about helping the reaction
community to prevent a kind of a lawsuit from Disney or Sony
that is so disingenuous and it's just false. It doesn't pass
the smell test at all. I resent it. And then second point, the
complaint's unhinged. You have a strong case. Just present the
case. Don't be a loser idiot. Hire some lawyer who either doesn't
know what he's doing or you're telling him to do this kind of
unhinged. It's sloppy. Tons of typos, formatting errors. It's
impossible to read. It's so if you really cared about protecting
the reaction community, you wouldn't use that filing, dude. You
wouldn't do that. Filled with venom, filled with, you know, not
getting to the facts, not getting to the point. This was a hit
piece. Wait, hold on. Sorry. I'm kidding. Just because it's Listen,
it's been in here. Somebody just said sent me this time stamp
said watch it real quick. This is kind of a title. Reddit says
the cho out loud. Israelis equal Zionist. Like that's kind of
definitionally true, right? Isn't it? Like if you're an Israeli,
you kind of are a Zionist now. What? I hope this is the right
time sterally is the manifestation of Zionism. Is this it? This
supposed to be about orbiters leaving or something. Anti fans
behavior and sentiment is so prevalent in your community. Why
is that? Um I mean like my the work anti-fan behavior is so prevalent
in your community theory that I have and the way that I've seen
it um work out is that um it feels like uh there's a lot of social
credit and validation for kind of like taking an opposite position.
Riyle, this is your time stamp. And joining a community like
remember if you are I feel like if you are um Okay. Like if you're
part of my community,
you're you're right here. Okay. You're a lithium, sodium, potassium.
Who the cares about these three ones, right? But you're one of
these guys. It's like a highly volatile, very unstable. You need
a lot of work to not
But then all of the other kind of online communities seem far
more stable. It's like once you're there, you've got a lot of
like support from other people in the community. There's a ton
of comment or content creators. Like if you watch my stuff and
then I'm sorry, I just had to I just read a Discord message and
I think once you're there, you've got a lot of like support.
Sorry, I have to I have to I have to
volatile. Sorry, I I got a message about mod actions in the Discord.
Very unstable. You need a lot of work to not explode.
But then all of the other kind of online communities seem far
more stable. It's like once you're there, you've got a lot of
like support from other people in the community. There's a ton
of comment or content creators. Like if you watch my stuff and
then I'm offline like who do you watch otherwise? Like it's kind
of I don't know. There's not very many people it feels that do
the same kind of thing that I do. But if you are um Oh, I see.
If you are um if you like watch a son and then offline, there's
like 100 other progressive content creators or ML content creators
you can watch. Oh. Oh, this is guys. I don't have anybody who's
around me. Oh, do you think he's going to think about or introspect
at all on the reason why he doesn't have a bunch of content creators
who like align with him anymore? Who like don't really watch
his stuff and like kind of do he had this. He was actually famous
for having this precisely. He was literally famous for this.
Exactly. So basically we'll say all the same or if you're like
a MAGA person and like your MAGA whatever person offline. There's
no way he just sits here with zero introspection,
with zero commentary on why this is the case and just says, "I'm
alone, guys." Like, if you're Hassan, he's got like waiting rooms.
He's got like friends. He's got people who who take his opinions
and like re reparro them. Okay. Oh my god. There's like a hundred
other content creators you can watch. So yeah, I feel like that
instability being on my side of the internet probably makes it
so that when you transfer out like you end up full on joining
other things. But to be fair, it's not like I don't I'm not saying
I've seen He's trying to He's trying to point out how people
leave him and then they totally take like completely different
and insane positions or something, right? Oh, well, when you
leave me, you go and like you you have to cozy up to Hassan and
agree with all of Hassan's takes. That's just not the case. It's
a totally disingenuous like review of other content creators
who were kind of adjacent to him before. Okay. It's crazy. Hold
on. We got uh we got Trump, guys. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Oh, lots of different things. You know, I can't rewind.
Why can't I rewind on the White House's own thing? Wait, what
the Hold on. Is this going to be it? Trump to address the nation
at 10 p.m. Uh, increasing. Wait, what the is going on? Why did
I get linked this? Why did I get linked such a version of this?
What about the presidential address isn't even on yet, is it?
What the [__] Oh, hang on a moment here. One one
moment. I don't think this is it. The White House feed. I got
the White House feed, too. Let me put up the White House feed.
I want the official White House feed. Hold on. Yeah, we're we're
like not even there yet. What are you doing, Tao? What are you
doing, buddy? You just linked me some random thing, brother.
Anybody do that? You got to be better than that. To be kind of
a trend, but okay. So, yeah. No critical thinking, no analysis,
nothing. Just nobody wants to be around me, guys. It's crazy.
New Russian occupied government. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Okay.
Cool. Okay, we're waiting on this. Yeah. No, I've got it. I've
got it up here. We're back Pisco for his conclusion still or
back to his conclusion again. Um, somebody linked the time stamp
for Desty's Apparently Destiny doesn't really react to this that
much. Wasn't Destiny complaining that Lykan is not supporting
Ethan's lawsuit just because he hates him or some Yeah, we covered
that earlier.
Filled with venom, filled with, you know, not getting to the
facts, not getting to the point. This was a hippie in the formal
again at Jay's dog. Again, what happened when this dude talked
about how Vash and Hassan always makes claims about other people
without pulling up a clip? Uh, he literally doesn't have any
principles,
zero principles, illegal violent. And maybe it's even true on
some base accusations. But don't pretend you're here for the
broader reaction community when you file that piece of you're
not doing anyone any help. What could a settlement real like
if they were looking for a settlement be like an offer, right?
I watched a little bit of that. That's the problem. This is like
a legal this is a lawsuit. Sorry. It's a manifesto and PR piece.
Masqueraden has a lawsuit with the twist that it's actually probably
a strong legal case. Yeah, exactly.
It's just it's all done for PR. And by the way, I think Pisco
is missing out on the fact that there are going to be more and
more lawyers like this. There are so many people who think that
hey like there are so many people who want to do something legally
or they want the the veneer of legal legitimacy. Okay. And not
even veneer. Yeah. They want the veneer of like legal legitimacy.
Ethan happens to have a good legal case here. Right. But I think
he would do this anyway. And I think he has done stuff like this
anyway. This is to my mind like pretty much what the Noah Samson
lawsuit was, right? It's like the same thing where hey the the
lawyer is going to help you manage PR through the legal system.
That is like actually their goal. That's what Bretler does, right?
We're managing PR through the legal system because actually you're
a famous person. You rely on having an audience. That's how you
make your money. I'm going to make sure you don't lose your audience.
I'm going to make sure that your audience knows you're taking
every legal option available and your legal filings will reflect
your public positions. I think that's like that's like the pitch
that's getting sold and I think people will pony up. And yeah,
maybe maybe you like get in trouble. Maybe you have like some
issues with like the like maybe you know a judge gets mad at
you or something, but who cares? Even if you face, even if you
lose in court, even if Ethan loses this in court, it won't matter.
Why would Why would the damages from him losing in court matter
to him at all for this case? They don't. But that's not the primary
purpose, but they can't get statutory damages because they've
filed uh they pre-registered it. So, that's another twist. So,
yeah, it looks like they're trying to make it hurt. He wants
to make it hurt and he's going to do that. If I were Denims in
company, I would get a very aggressive lawyer because I don't
I don't think that they're going to be reasonable. The filing
is not reasonable, and it looks like you're going to go through
some through some things. And I would be like, "Your honor, we're
moving for sanctions. We're motioning to strike all of this as
irrelevant. This is clearly an attempt to abuse the process and
smear these people and its fair use because of this, but it'll
be expensive and painful and a total waste of our judicial system
to go through like all like if it think losing the case is very
important to Ethan and the people following this. Wait, losing?
No, no, no. I'm saying even if they lost, it wouldn't matter.
No, it's about the process. It's not about the outcome of the
case. It's about the process and how much you can convince people
that you're going to win. There are going to be there will be
no you don't even have to think about like what happens after
the case. Look at what just happened with his case with the other
guy, right? He he's he said, "Oh, I won this case." Uh he basically
came out and had to say, "You know what? I I did some stuff.
I have to go edit all my VODs and take out all my claims about
this guy. Okay, I have to go part of my settlement, right? I
can't defame this guy." And nobody cares. It doesn't matter that
he was defaming the guy. It doesn't matter, right? because he
settled it and now it's totally like it has zero effect on his
streaming that he was a totally disingenuous lying about oh I
lost the guy's name off the top of my head but it doesn't matter
that he lied about that guy right he's just going to go edit
his old VODs and nobody cares there's not going to be a single
peep about it from anybody audience is totally undisturbed it
were a clean copyright infringement case okay I wouldn't say
it's a waste of our judicial system and I would maybe even say
I'm not against suing these people but the way this Kavanagh
Ryan Kavanaaugh yep it leaves it back to mouth but suing the
right of mods is pretty pretty Funny. Pretty good meme. Pretty
funny. You don't think they would settle the symbol of public
apology of what? I'm sorry for what? That's the question, right?
And it's it's a great question, right? What is what are they
sorry for? What does Ethan want them to be sorry for? He doesn't
want them to be sorry for it. Thank you for membership. He doesn't
want them to be sorry for copyright infringement. That's not
what's going on here. And you have to be very like
that's what they want apology for. Yes. Sorry for stealing your
video. XQC stole your video. He's not actually mad about that.
He's mad about these people because of who they are, not what
they did or what they did on other stuff, not this. That's it.
What do you want to say? It's why they blame it. Yeah. I mean,
yeah. No one ever said these people are like smart. Yeah. I don't
think you can move to dismiss this. I think it does state a claim
upon which rel relief could be granted. So, I don't think you
can move to dismiss this. Doesn't seem dismissible
unless there's some jurisdictional thing I'm not thinking about,
but there's clearly subject matter jurisdiction. Maybe there's
some personal jurisdiction or venue issue that I'm not. Okay.
That's pretty much that's most of Pisco's analysis of this. I
think we got there last night. Um, that it seems like there's
a real case here. I don't think it's going to be transformative
enough.